um
so
this
is
please remember remain standing for
prayers
good evening councillors good evening
members of the public shall we pray
father in the midst of this evening help
us to always be mindful
of actually friends family and
communities that are struggling
particularly mindful of communities
and businesses devastated by the recent
floods
help us to be mindful of their needs
yet lord in our midst tonight we pray
also that you would guide us by your
holy spirit
gracious lord you would give us
wisdom in all that is discussed and
debated
father you give us mutual respect of one
another's views and opinions as shared
this evening
and lord in all that is said all that is
shared you would be honoured in our
midst
we ask all these things in jesus
christ's name
amen amen amen
thank you thank you
right
welcome members
officers and members of the public to
this meeting on the 18th of february
2020
it's good to see so many members of the
public in attendance tonight but can i
remind them that although you are all
very welcome at this meeting you are not
permitted to speak at the meeting i
would ask you to respect this and allow
counselors to hear all the points that
being made
members we have a heavy agenda this
evening and i would also and a lot of
residents in attendance for the two
petitions i would there would like to
move a motion without notice 14c
has set out on page 410 of the
constitution in order to ensure that we
manage to get through the statutory
reports on the agenda for example the
council tax setting report to change the
agenda
running order as follows
items one to five are set out on the
agenda
then items 13 through to 16 in numerical
order
and then items 6 through to 12 in
numerical order
thank you very much
i shall now take item one on the agenda
apologies for absence
chairman thank you uh
councillor bob milne has given his
apologies in the office today are there
any other apologies members
no thank you very much
i shall now take item two on the amen
and the on the agenda minutes of the
meeting held on the 11th of february
2020
okay
council mrs mason
thank you mr chairman um not an heiress
as such but there is an
item of omission
on page five fourth paragraph
the vote was taken on a show of hands is
correct but we uh
asked for a count of energy 15 18 and we
asked for that to be noted and it hasn't
been out noted so ask that to be added
to the minutes
secondly and this is a small point it's
um
on the recommendations we had 12 votes
taken
on four of those
the numbers of votes do not add up to
the numbers of
members present and i would ask that
in future i realize we can't go back
retrospectively on this but in future
there is
care taken to make sure that the number
of votes cast do match up to the number
of members
voting thank you
thank you mrs mason
okay
i've been told council mrs mason that
the numbers don't necessarily add up
because some councillors
did did not vote on some of the items
thank you if that's the case mr chairman
we have abstentions we have form we have
against so if we have what do we have i
don't know
we need to have another category so that
it does add up thank you
not voting
mrs council mrs mason it's not required
in in the constitution but i i note your
comments thank you
agenda item three members declarations
of interest do members have any interest
to declare
no thank you very much
agenda item for announcements from the
paid from the chairman leader or head of
paid service
there are no announcements from the
leader of the head of paid service
members but i would like to remind you
members of my civic dinner to be held on
the 6th of march 2020
and my charity quiz night to be held on
the 20th of march 2020
it would be nice to see as many of you
there as possible and possibly some
members of the public perhaps
thank you
agenda item 5 presentation of petitions
pursuant to rule 11.
members we have two petitions to present
to be presented this evening
the first petition will be presented by
mr david miles who will have a total of
five minutes to present it
after that members we have a total of 15
minutes in which to debate the petition
just 15 minutes i will ask the portfolio
holder for planning to respond to the
petition in the first instance and then
we'll invite other members to contribute
to debate
as we only have 15 minutes in total and
i want as many members as possible to
have an opportunity to speak can i
please ask you to be as concise and as
brief as possible
mr miles
you will have the opportunity at end of
the debate to sum up for a maximum of
one minute if you
outrage from wish
sorry
as many people know there is
widespread outrage from residents
throughout the district that the core
strategy that has led to understandable
over development
the local infrastructure and especially
highways is not coping with the
development completed so far let alone
those sites which planning is due to be
submitted before 2025.
the council intends for the cost
strategy to be simply taken forward
unchanged into a new local plan 2017 to
2037.
the council does not expect the new
local plan to be adopted until 2023 at
the earliest
the day 12 years after the adoption of
the course strategy certainly does not
fulfill the legal requirement for an
early review as was legally required by
plan inspector laura graham
the ceo planning spectra lawfully
required that rdc
do an early review of the local plan
this was not done
had the council undertaken such a review
then the findings of acom would also
have been taken into account that's the
growth and infrastructure framework for
rochford district
now just diverging slightly you know as
residents we have certain lawful duties
to pay our council tax not to fly tip
not to park illegally
and
likewise we expect the people that
represent us on the council to act legal
the same within the legal framework
that's established
you know you if you have a society where
you pick and cherry pick even or pick
and choose which parts of
the legal system you want to adhere to
then you know becomes a pretty poor
system where we just say oh no we don't
want to do this bit but we do that bet
anyway carrying on the council would you
know
then had i've had to have reconsidered
the sustainability of the car strategy
since the early review of the cost
strategy has not been undertaken and has
been unilaterally ignored by the council
this has led to planned decisions being
made which are detrimental to residents
and will be exacerbated if the sre r8 is
approved in a planning application
if roxford district council not do not
appear to have confidence in the legal
requirements placed upon them how can
constituents reasonably be expected to
have confidence in them and their
decision making
this has led to the vote of no
confidence petitioning rockford district
council thank you
thank you mr myles
[Applause]
councillor world cup please ask you to
respond to the petition
council awards you have five minutes in
which to respond
thank you chairman
the key point of concern raised in the
petition
is that a review of the core strategy
has not been carried out by the council
together with insufficient investment in
infrastructure unsustainable over
development and material economic damage
firstly
a question
why was there a commitment to carry out
an early review of the core strategy
i'll explain the course strategy itself
was adopted in 2011
and an early review took place in march
2012 in response to the inspector's
letter of august 2011 which i quote some
salient points
in all circumstances and to avoid any
further delay i am minded to suggest
that the council considers proposing
changes to the plan which would
acknowledge the shortfall in the planned
period briefly explaining the
circumstances and making a firm
commitment
to an early review of the plan
i'm of the view that such changes could
be considered minor
and would not require formal
consultation or sustainability
assessment i continue
this course of action would be a
pragmatic way of ensuring the council
has a core strategy in place to guide
development whilst it undertakes a
revision of the plan in accordance with
the new legislative and policy framework
in regard to the allocations plan it was
not finally adopted until 2014 both the
core strategy and the allocations plan
were publicly examined and tested by an
independent inspector and both were
found to be sound and suitable for
adoption
the soundness of the plans was further
tested through legal challenges but no
issues were subsequently identified
regarding the way the plans have been
prepared by the council
there is a specific reason for the
recommendation by the inspector for an
early review of the course strategy and
this did not relate to any shortcomings
in the contents or soundness of the plan
progress of the plan through public
examination to adoption was delayed as a
result of the imminent arrival of a new
national planning policy framework and
at the same time the proposed revocation
of regional plans
the delay meant the core strategy as
submitted technically did not cover a
15-year period
the inspector as explained raised no
issues with the soundness of the plan
but did accept the benefits of an early
review to ensure the plan covered at
least a 15-year period
this early review of the core strategy
recommend commenced march in 2012 and
its outcomes are a matter of record
the core strategy and the allocations
plan and other policy documents form the
planning
framework for the district to be
implemented by 2025
for the plans to be sound every site
allocation that's housing employment
etcetera was tested to ensure it could
be sustainably delivered and the
specific infrastructure requirements for
every housing site are set out in a in
appendix eight one of the adopted core
strategy
and in the individual site policies set
out in the allocation plan
for planning consent to be granted for
development on the allocated sites the
developer must agree to provide all the
infrastructure requested in order to
fully mitigate the impact of their
development
the council is currently working on the
preparation of a new local plan
it's worth noting that the new local
plan will effectively compromise the
contents of a core strategy and an
allocations plan
the petitioner makes a point about
material economic damage
though it should be recognizable
plans
are intended to address a range of
social economic and environmental
matters
the current core strategy and allocation
plans also include proposals for
economic development and the area action
plan prepared jointly with southend
borough council provide for the
development of the airport and a new
business park
far from creating material economic
damage has suggested the council's plans
are focused on economic regeneration and
development with housing as an essential
part of that equation because of the
reasons previously stated and we
currently have embarked on our new local
plan i propose no further action thank
you chaim
council steptoe
thank you german i second that
proposition and i reserve the right to
speak at the end of debativeness thank
you counter steptoe
um i have a number of people wishing to
speak counsel mrs mason
could i ask all speakers to be concise
please
i will do my best mr chairman thank you
for calling me
in december 2011 this council adopted
the court strategy
and in line with the inspector's
requirement committed to an early review
the council
did not do that in my view in a timely
fashion
and it is regularly reporting that it
cannot progress the agreed dates on the
new local plan 2017
to
2037. we are three years past that date
you will note
if the council had acted promptly
on the earlier review this would have
enabled residents to have certainty
and prevented all the current upset and
stress
calls to residents because a possible
extension of the core strategy could
have been undertaken alongside
known infrastructure
deficits
the problem
with inadequate infrastructure and
dances to the sustainability of current
and future development in our area is
not only documented
but experienced by all of us on a
regular basis
therefore it is no
surprise
though of great regret
that so many residents have supported a
vote of no confidence and this whole
matter needs to be referred urgent
reviewed urgently by the council
initially i would think at the review
committee and then with the planning
inspector whose directions
need to be taken into account because
this council has failed to conduct a
timely review that was committed in 2011
this council has failed to provide
adequate resources to ensure
that this was conducted and that the new
local plan is carried out efficiently in
a timely fashion
in brief
in my view this council has
spectacularly failed its residence in
this respect thank you thank you
councilman
councillor mrs mcpherson
[Applause]
thank you chairman um sorry i haven't
got a mic but i'm usually quite loud
enough anyway counsellor bear with me um
i need to repeat your name it's council
mrs mcpherson thank you councilman
councilman beerson could you please use
the mic because we have uh audio
recording upstairs for the benefit of uh
residency upstairs it's on so if you
could speak into them yeah if you could
speak into the mic that'd be great thank
you okay
um
okay first of all i would like to thank
cam councillor award for his account
his role as councillor with the
portfolio for planning is not a position
that i will ever see a queue for is a
painful thankless task with housing
numbers pushed onto local councils from
successive governments
so to recap the then head of planning
produced a report that led the
development subcommittee to choose
option e the fuller review then started
on 2015 as part of the new local plan
the problem is this is not seen as good
enough by our residents
and i empathize completely with our
residents
our residents must be listened to and
their concerns addressed
the allocations plan was adopted in 2014
this is six years ago
it is important that we don't just roll
over existing policies in our new plan
we must review our spatial strategy and
policies in the light of up-to-date
evidence and guidance
for example the impact of developments
on climate change the environment have
currently reviewed their flood
management plans for
2021-2027 within the revision
that council award has mentioned i am
hoping that all new guidance and
emerging evidence will be included and
their impact on any allocations past and
present are considered
then finally there is the elephant in
the room
essex county council highways
i do not have long enough to say what i
would like to say about essex county
highways
but i would like to see our county
councillors as a collective
challenge highways decisions
i know our county councillors and trust
me they can be quite formidable on their
own
i hope post this meeting my suggestion
will be acted upon not as lip service
but as a formidable force that demand
better from highways scrutinise their
decisions and will not accept any
compromises thank you
thank you um mr chairman
as the first person to flee without a
prepared speech no doubt this will go
very badly wrong
i've listened to councillor walden as
ever he read his script very well
i perhaps may have less sympathy than
others with the role because it's the
role you've chosen to do however
difficult it may be
i cannot add anything much to what
counselor mrs
mcpherson says or counseling mrs mason i
would have said everything as well that
they have said
the the review
as i saw it has not been undertaken
the shortage of numbers have never been
addressed adequately the real issue
which this petition goes to
is around the lack of infrastructure and
the the lack of planning around that
i will reiterate what councilman
mcpherson says we as a council are not
hard enough to question what we get back
from essex highways they say that
everything is adequate where we know
when we live here that things are not
with regard to the local planners past
i'll give an example where this council
fails itself as well
when
the
pla the um local plan was adopted
originally
there was specific mention by the
inspector in his report that walter
elaine
must be addressed properly must be
improved properly not by putting a few
lanes in just in advance of it to ease
traffic moving into it it's he said this
must be addressed before any development
is made at ser six when this big that
became
became in front came in front of the
planning committee that was totally
ignored so this council should also look
upon itself which is what this motion is
going to the to so i would
not i would support the motion in the
aims of the motion i don't think i could
support councillor
walt's motion however thank you thank
you councillor
councilwoman
council mr fd hello
i also empathize with residents but it's
my understanding if the course strategy
is revoked
developers will be able to apply for
planning permission on any land for any
number of houses across the district
thank you thank you
councillor mr hookway
thank you chairman um
i would
pick up on a particular point which
hasn't been raised
basically the uh
the success of any plan is uh not at the
time of when it's drawn up but actually
during the process that it's
enacted and
how it is implemented
there has been one particular area which
i feel that the plan is severely deficit
and could be deemed as a failure
and hopefully this might be addressed
uh in the new local plan
uh what i'm talking about is in relation
to uh travel sites
uh in the core strategy there is an
allocation for a traveler site however
this site is unlikely
to come forward in any near future
and in
recent
planning applications
this has been a matter that has caused
problems for um councillors when that
when we've been looking at various
planning applications
for
sites where people have occupied sites
and then ask for retrospective planning
under normal circumstances
uh these uh these particular sites bear
in mind they're normally on
greenfield sites or
or are protected sites they would not
in any way
be considered appropriate for
development
however because of
the
our current plan fails to provide travel
sites
within a appropriate time scale
a number of these uh these applications
although they may have been refused at
planning have gone on to be appealed and
some of which have been successful
this is obviously a failure of the
original core strategy
and it is one area
where there is a real problem
a number of people will look at
matters of infrastructure and i support
the arguments around infrastructure it
does seem that there are questions
relating to
infrastructure needs that seem to be
just batted away without any real
consideration
and i find that a very worrying
situation thank you
councillors unfortunately the 15 minutes
for debate is now finished
council ward can i ask you to summarise
your motion briefly please
[Music]
thank you chairman
the petitioner required a formal debate
in council which we've just had
i would like to thank all those who have
contributed and all their contributions
would have been noted in conjunction
with the current work the council has
been embarking on
regarding the preparation of a new local
plan to run until 2037
the issues and options consultation on
the new plan was carried out in 2018
the requirements for future housing
development in the district are now
calculated by government formula and the
objectively assessed housing need the
oan for the period to 2037. this need
has been calculated as being
385 dwellings per annum
the new local plan will need to set out
a strategy to explain how delivery of
these houses will be achieved
i'm pleased to announce the formation of
a new planning policy working group
drawn from members across the chamber
who will work in conjunction with our
planning officers to consider our
options into the future as previously
stated i propose we take no further
action thank you chairman thank you
council steptoe would you like to come
up come back
chairman just to reaffirm i second the
council awards motion thank you
mr miles
you have one minute to say anything i'd
like to move an amendment to the motion
please
i'm afraid councillor wilkinson that the
15 minutes for debate i i i asked just
i had my hand up before the end of the
15 minutes chairman to move
the motion but the 15 minutes had
expired and whilst council hawkway was
speaking
he's just put the motion
alternative motion because the 15
minutes was up
and there was a motion proposing
seconded on the floor
mr miles
thank you mr chairman as i was so brief
for my first reading i think it was just
over two minutes i would appreciate you
giving me just a little bit of latitude
to run 30 seconds over
um first of all um the
counsellor down there twice mentioned
that there will be no further action i
think when it comes to rockford district
council you can actually read that as in
action
because that's what rochefort council
does
i mean
you know i think the changes we you know
we the council think they can feed
residents a few crumbs and they'll go
away toe the line like good little boys
and girls as long gone
let's take the christmas tree farm
retreat road you widen the junction
slightly so you allowed one more car
there do you honestly think that sold a
traffic problem
you know you talk about infrastructure
what infrastructure where is it
residents have eyes you know we are no
longer stupid we're not blind
[Applause]
where is this infrastructure please i'd
like to see it where are the extra
doctors
i mean you know where are the hospitals
where are the extra roads where is the
bloody infrastructure if you excuse my
french
you know it is absolutely ridiculous you
can no longer treat us like mushrooms i
won't coin the actual phrase but we will
no longer be kept in the dark and fed
with a certain
nutrient let's put it that way
you know residents have had enough of
you guys sitting in a closed
chamber and just deciding our future
with no regard to us
enough is enough as the labour party
learned to their detriment in the
detriment in the general election
you know you can be replaced very easily
in the heartlands of the conservative
party
of the sorry the labour party they lost
seats that have been held
historically for 80 years
i'm just saying people have had enough
you know you can talk nice words you can
you know make platitudes but it no
longer washes the people are awake and
they know what's going on they know
there's no new infrastructure they know
you're building beyond capacity and it
is no longer acceptable thank you very
much thank you
[Applause]
members we have one motion moved by
council ward and seconded by council
steps i would like to move information
without notice please in accordance with
the constitution and i propose to move
this matter to the review board is for a
second
[Applause]
there's only three options
is
counselor mr boy we're checking that one
out
[Music]
yes
um
it's not a body it's a it's a committee
of the
it's not a body it's a committee of the
council
and
and there are only three options
uh on the agenda
you can only have one of the three on
the agenda
and we have a proposal and a seconder
for one of those
options
sorry are you saying chairman that the
um
you're disallowing the motion without
notice
because i don't understand what basis is
being refused
i would ask you council mr highway
respect to
look at the agenda there are only three
options there
chairman my understanding devotion
without notice can be moved at any time
and there is precedent for this earlier
when the 2030
motion
which has now been carried and moved to
review board was moved after emotion
closed
that counts as mr was a motion not a
petition and there is a difference
right
sorry chairman there was a motion moved
but this council mr hoy it's a petition
not a motion
sorry chairman a motion was proposed by
councillor wald which was seconded by
councillor steptoe
in accordance with the agenda
members i go back to
the motion that has been moved by
council ward and seconded by council
steptoe is that agreed members
[Applause]
there will be recorded vote members
cancer mrs belton
councillor burton
councillor mrs butcher
councillor canal
councillor mr carter
councillor mrs carter
councillor catmore four
councillor dre four
council referee four
councillor eves
councillor mrs gooding
councillor hazelwood
councillor hookway
against
cancer mrs hoye
councillor mr hoyer
councillor hudson
cancer yuani
cancer lucas gill
council mrs lumley
councillor mrs mason
cancer mrs mcpherson
councillor merrick
counselor newport
councillor mrs pavlin
councillor mrs rowe
councillor mrs shaw
councillor mr shaw
councillor smith
councillor sparing
councillor stanley
councillor steptoe
councillor ward
councillor webb
councillor mrs weston
councillor wilkinson
against
councillor williams
councillor wilson
and councillor witton
members
there were 26 votes for 11 against and
two abstentions and therefore the motion
is approved thank you members
mr miles
you will receive a written copy of the
council's response to your petition and
a copy will also be uploaded on the
council website
uh mr miles and members of the public
you are more than welcome to stay for
the remainder remainder of the business
if you'd like to leave please do so
either by the door at the back of the
chamber on the right hand side which
will take you outside to the side of the
building or through the door at the
front of the chamber thank you
i mentioned
sorry is it um would it be appropriate
to invite members of the public who are
remaining upstairs perhaps come
downstairs so they can see
yeah there's a lot of people going
i think you've just done that
yes
it depends
chairman um
would it be possible for
myself and other counselors to have a
written explanation of the reason the
emotional notice was mostly emotion
without notice was refused so we may
understand it better in the future thank
you
chairman during the debate sorry excuse
me
so during the debate um
council ward had already moved a motion
for no further action the debate was had
to be within time 15 minutes the
proposals that um
that were laid down in the report are
taking the action requested
taking the request action requested not
taking the action requested or
commissioned further investigation
the motion was already being voted and
it was voted on to move an amendment
after that you can't
well the motion had been moved so we
would have to vote yeah but we would
have to vote on that once the motion's
on floor we have to deal with that we
have to deal with that vote first
and then come back if there was
amendments then we would deal with the
amendment first and if that was lost we
were going back to the original motion
yes ma'am have that in writing please
yes
if there are any members of the public
still in a room four they can come down
to the main chamber thank you
members will now go on to the second
petition which presented by mr gareth
james
mr james
you will have a total of five minutes to
present it
after that members we have a total of 15
minutes in which to debate the petition
i don't ask the portfolio holder for
planning to respond to the petition in
the first instance and then we'll invite
other members to contribute to debate
and as we only have 15 minutes in total
at last as many members as possible have
an opportunity to speak can i please i
should be concise and as brief as
possible
james we're just waiting for people to
come down from uh come up from
downstairs so i apologize
[Music]
mr james you will have the opportunity
at the end of the debate to sum up for a
maximum of one minute if you wish to do
so
and you will have five minutes to speak
and i will
remind you when you have one minute left
thank you
good evening my name is gareth james i'm
a member of the rayleigh residence
association
i'm here to see
i'm here this evening not only
representing the people who live and
work in rayleigh but all residents and
workers across the rochford district
over 1500 of whom have signed the
petition demanding that rochford council
stop approving any more planning
applications without the improvements
that are essential to the infrastructure
firstly to avoid any confusion i would
like to address the wording of this
petition
i want to make it crystal clear we are
not against development we appreciate
there is a housing crisis which the
current and previous governments have
failed to address i personally work in
construction i benefit from a thriving
house building industry but it has to be
the right type of housing and has to be
the right type of infrastructure in
place prior to development starting
our current government promised in 2015
to build 200 000 starter homes but as
far as i know they haven't been built
our concerns are that currently
developers are allowed to do as they
wish
the council seemed reluctant to enforce
their own policies and are often more
concerned with the developers profit
margins
why have policies on items such as
minimum number of car parking spaces
sizes of car parking spaces and more
importantly the percentage of affordable
housing incorporated into development
has often been ignored
can the council confirm tonight if
developers are regularly allowed to
deviate from such policies purely to
protect their profit margins
where is the affordable housing the
countryside development on roar of lane
is made up of three to five bedroom
properties ranging from four hundred and
fifty thousand to six hundred and
seventy thousand
another much smaller development at the
bottom of hanborough hill only
consisting of four four bedroom
properties are priced at 630 000 and
have been on the market for months
what properties are available for
first-time buyers in this district
could you also confirm this evening if
the allocated affordable housing or
housing association stock on the
countryside development is offered to
local residents as there are examples of
other developments around the district
where housing associations from london
have purchased large numbers of
properties
another question resident residents
would like explained is where does the
cash given to you by developers as a
contribution towards infrastructure go
it's very common for developers to make
promises before starting developments
that doctors community facilities
schools etc will be built but they
rarely materialize
however more importantly before any
developments even progress through
planning the adequate infrastructure
should be considered
i believe the council have already
admitted our roads are at or close to
maximum capacity
it only takes one set of temporary
traffic lights somewhere in rayleigh
for the whole town to grind to a halt
where is the investment in this district
are there any large infrastructure
investments expected are the councils
sat on cash reserves of 10 million
pounds
are they planning to sell
assets including this building to raise
3.4 million for their new offices
are they tonight going to vote to raise
our council tax by the maximum they're
allowed to
i have lived in raleigh for five years
and the traffic has definitely got worse
the disaster is planning a few months
ago where districts and county councils
attempted to blame each other caused
absolute chaos with multiple
developments all starting road works at
the same time
this cannot be allowed to happen again
but residents can surely expect more
travel chaos over the next few months
and the plan to build thousands of new
homes is ever going to improve
the prime minister has been making a
whole range of pledges regarding
infrastructure investment i
understand they have set 80 billion
aside is this council pressurizing the
county council demanding that there are
investments made in our roads
maybe instead of trying to squeeze as
many houses as possible on every
available piece of open land some of
which we know are prone to flooding mr
james you have one minute left
this council should be working with
other neighbouring councils and looking
into proposing sites for a new for
building a new town there have been
plans submitted for a new community
close to chelmsford consisting of 5 000
homes this seems to make much more sense
as adequate infrastructure is all can be
put in place at the start
it's also been announced basildon
council are making a 10 million
investment in the regeneration of
wickford town centre
where is the investment in this district
i hope tonight we see a positive outcome
and the council formally acknowledges
that this can't continue
the police fire and crime commissioner
meets the public of rochford and i'm
sure the residents would be keen for a
public meeting with the council to
discuss the over development issue
you cannot continue to allow houses to
be built before addressing our concerns
within infrastructure and we do not
accept it's not in your remit as our
elected representatives you should be
challenging the other authorities
involved to address these concerns
i look forward to hearing your response
to our concerns
thank you mr james
council ward could i ask you to respond
to a petition you have five minutes in
which to do so
thank you chairman
uh let me stop my response by addressing
each point as many of the points raised
we haven't got enough time
to really address them all as i would
like
with regard to housing
that you've made the point we do have 35
of all housing that comes on that has to
go
in regards to local needs and as far as
you were mentioning about a housing that
is being from outside boroughs none of
that is happening in any way shape or
form unless they are buying it privately
on the private market that none of that
occurs
so just carrying on uh whilst we have
complaints about multiple roadworks
which i agree do cause a major
disruption
there are an investment in
infrastructure as a result as a result
of developers
providing improvements to the road
network
that said on the matter of roadworks a
developers forum has been set up by
essex county council and rochefort
district council to ensure there is a
planned approach to road closures in
future obviously with the exception of
emergency repairs
this forum was initiated by mark
francois who incidentally is bringing
forward a private member's bill on the
control of roadworks
this will meet regularly to discuss the
programs for highway works with the aim
of ensuring maximum coordination
together with minimum disturbance for
rodeo for road users
i know that you mentioned in your
original thing with regard to
environment and and the problems there
the council does take the potential
risks of pollution from road users and
other sources seriously and we're
obliged under the environment act 1995
to monitor air quality and we review and
assess air quality in the district
against the government's national air
quality objectives
information regarding air quality across
the district is available on the
council's website
you'll find the 2019 annual status
report which shows compliance across the
district reports are submitted to defra
for approval annually and contain
details of all our monitoring locations
data and trends
the council will continue to work to
minimise the influence of local vehicle
emissions across the district including
the recent introduction of electric
vehicle charging points
thirdly the current housing numbers for
the period
2025 are set out in the adopted core
strategy 2011 and the allocation plan
2014.
these were robustly tested through
public examination prior to adoption by
the council and were also challenged by
way of judicial review
to set aside both the core strategy and
the allocation plan will place the
council and its residents at risk of
litigation and paying substantial
financial compensation to developers and
landowners
it will be a reckless council that would
give any consideration to an attempt to
set the current plans aside
additionally
a local authority without a plan to
control and manage development may very
well be an open target for ad hoc
developments something we know our
residents wouldn't want
i must emphasise every new housing
scheme must contribute to the provision
of new infrastructure to fully mitigate
the impact of that development
the infrastructure requirements for each
new housing site are set out in detail
in the core strategy allocation plan
every developer of the sites allocated
in the plans will be contributing in
full to the infrastructure demands of
the various organizations involved
including essex highways the nhs county
education etc lastly the comments about
the need you made for permanent sites we
were talking about travelers i think
this was something that you brought up
in your little
thing
the need for sites for travelers lying
in the district
and secondly unauthorized temporary
encounter encampments incursions into
public parks there is a modest projected
requirement for a number of permanent
sites for travellers within the district
however the delivery of permanent sites
will have no impact on the likelihood of
incursions on public land in the future
the government is currently consulting
on a possible change in the trespass
legislation to allow the police and
local authorities council laws you have
one minute
with unauthorized encampments a solution
we have been waiting a long time for
finally in reference to a comment
suggested that councillors do not
respond to emails i noted that one
or where there is a response is not
considered to be adequate i personally
respond to all emails and like many of
my fellow counsellors prefer to engage
in one-to-one conversation with our
residents whilst endeavouring to always
give full and frank responses to the
questions asked
over the next few months there will be
ample opportunities for residents to
discuss the details of the next local
plan and i'd like to invite yourself and
your residents association to make to be
part of that
you know
i'll be happy to consider options for
public meetings as work progresses and
would ask residents to register online
if they haven't already done so about
future local plan meetings but in the
meantime
as it stands i would propose that
there'll be no further action and we
continue as we are doing now with our
local plans
chairman i'll second that uh proposition
and like like before i reserve the right
to speak at the end of the debate
thank you council step two um i have a
number of uh members who wish to speak
from the point of order i didn't quite
catch what the motion was i didn't
actually hear a motion
is it no further
can you repeat that counselor
yeah of course um i propose that there
have been no further action in light of
the local plan that we are developing
and that has been seconded council
wilkinson
thank you chairman
um
i
do not support that motion in any way
shape or form and whilst i have the
greatest respect for council award for
the difficult job that he does
he's
he spent five minutes not really
answering what rocha council is doing
has told us what mark francois is doing
and talked a lot about air quality and
the um
turning away of the core stretching
local plan now nobody's asking for the
call local the course strategy local
plan to be revoked i totally agree with
his comments that we shouldn't do but
that's not what the petition says so i'm
not sure why that's been mentioned or
why air quality was spoken about for
such a great length of time as important
subject that it is
the travellers sites are an important
issue um members will know no doubt the
correspondence has been going on between
parish council and our planning
departments just today regarding the
illegal or the expected legal
encampments in saint john's road
these are happening all the time and i
think it's
with respect slightly naive to think
that if we had a legitimate traveller
site that would stop the incursions
that's not going to happen
i also think
that
the rocha council response to the essex
county council consultation on
infrastructure contributions
was slightly worrying in its comments
around
marginal developments we appear to be
concerned
about marginal developments there's no
definition of what a marginal
development is
but the way that it's written it implies
that if the developer is going to have
marginal profits and maybe i'm reading
incorrectly between the lines but that's
how it reads
then
that may deter them from building in
which case we won't get a development in
which case we won't get affordable
housing so what we're saying is that
that is more important developers profit
margins is more important so we won't
ask for an infrastructure
contribution and it's slightly incorrect
to say
that we get contributions from every
single one i can quote two developments
the dairy crest proposal which is yet to
be ratified by the development committee
but certainly came forward development
last month and the starlain developed
both of which exceeded the 35 houses or
units neither which the planning
department were assisting any
contributions were made for there was no
affordable housing and no
um
infrastructure
development so it's not happening at all
um
i i think it's what we could do and what
we should be doing is we should be
looking at an independent
uh
consultant to look at our own
infrastructure needs because we are
blindly accepting what essex county
council say
uh it's not right i have a motion a
question or notice regarding the highway
so i'm not going to double up
however we are accepting what they say
and i think it's
i think we know without any party lines
here we all accept the fact that essex
county council starts on highways is not
ours and we need to do something about
that and i'm not hearing anything being
done about that at all so i move um that
we do have a public meeting that we
should have a public meeting with
residents because why not the police and
fire commissioner has a public meeting
regular residence the police have public
meetings with the residents
the local mp has public meetings with
residents he had it before brexit but we
don't we hide away okay we welcome
people into here but we don't give them
a chance to speak we give one person
five minutes and it's too regulated
why not why not have that meeting with
our residents and sit there talk about
their concerns
so chairman i avoid i move from
an alternative motion
that we do have a public meeting and we
do take on board the issues contained
within this petition
thank you
thank you council wilkinson
oh
yes
council wilson wilkinson um there is
only the three options to choose from as
per the agenda
one of which has been uh proposed and
seconded
okay
in that case then um chairman i move for
an alternative motion we commission
further work and further investigation
into this matter
and uh and necessarily send it to the
review committee
i fully accept
what council wilkinson is trying to get
across
and i did say
that i would welcome
as i said i would ask residents to
register online but i would happy to
consider options for public meetings as
the work progresses
so that is actually
as the work progresses so as we progress
our local plan i was quite happy with
that therefore
i would continue with my proposition as
it stands okay
wilkinson's motion
members we have a proposal and a second
uh for the motion on the floor and i
shall take a vote on that
chairman for clarification purposes
council ward has put a motion on the
floor there's not been an amendment to
that motion you're moving council
councillor wilkinson is moving a new
motion
so we have to deal with the motion of
the floor you're not moving an amendment
to that motion
in that case i move from an amendment to
the motion as maybe it's a play on words
but my i'm moving an amendment there how
are you moving the amendment for no
further action
that we do action we take action
and we said you're telling me we have to
choose one of the three
so i've chosen one of the three options
that would be a vote against it
no it's not you're not putting another
option forward
it's a new motion to change it to no
further would be negating that motion
you have to amend that emotion that's on
the floor
[Applause]
my turn
could i just ask for maybe some advice
then from our league our legal
representative that that i i'm i'm
trying to read this and i'm trying to do
the right thing here as you all know so
i'm moving an amendment that i don't
think no further action is the right
thing i think action is the right thing
i was asked what that actually is so and
i was told that to choose one of these
so i've chosen one of these so if you're
saying i can't choose one of these then
how do i move an amendment
well
the motion sorry
the champ
you need to move in a an actual
amendment
how you move it
it's a matter for you you are not you
cannot negate emotion that's on the
floor okay my amendment is that it's
that we don't take any further action
it's taking the review committee but
that's negating the actual original
motion you need to amend it
okay
right
i've got some more people who wish to
speak
clarity then can you please confirm that
if a motion is moved that no action be
taken we are unable to move any other
motion apart from no action
correct because the the rules are in the
constitution the count the council will
decide how to respond to the petition at
the meeting by either
taking the action requested in the
petition not taking the action requested
for reasons before debating commission
further investigation
council ward has put forward a motion to
uh no further action um
i would like to know we out of
politeness allowed the portfolio holder
to speak at which point he then moves
his motion we are at no point able to
move anything other than an amendment to
his motion at that point if if in all
cases
the first speaker which would always be
the portfolio holder moves motion of no
action that means we as accounts are
unable to do anything but follow that no
action that doesn't seem to be within
the spirit or the wording of the rules
that counsel how high is as per the
constitution um i wanted to come back
council will so i've got some other
speakers and we're running out of time
councillor eves
thank you chairman i am
somewhat disturbed about the way that
this is being handled tonight but that's
another thing for another time um
to put my remarks in context um i was
born about 100 yards up the road from
where i live in hawkwell so i have seen
a huge change in the traffic flow in the
area and by huge i mean huge
when i've been on the development
committee and questioned issues
regarding highways i've always been told
well that's the rules
okay so then the natural assumption with
that then is with what we're seeing on
the ground and what we're seeing with uh
the residents being here tonight is
there's a problem with the rules
so
i then contacted
officers who said well that's sacrosanct
we can't do anything about that
i contacted highways and they said
exactly the same thing so i'm thinking
right well what can i do
so these rules are put in place
by recommendations from the uh
from the
highway engineering
our engineers institute i got in touch
with them
and i explained the situation that we
have in this area here and the society
has changed in that where we have a road
like the b1013 you have deliveries being
done all the time now
and every time there's a div redone the
road backs up
we have a situation where quite a few
years ago we were it was reported that
the b101 one three excuse me was at 80
capacity now i understand that 80
capacity is actually full
now that is a number of years ago
so we've all we cannot fail to notice
that there has been a big increase in
the amount of traffic on our roads now
when we are considering this in context
of the rules
i would suggest that myself being a lone
voice
asking and questioning about the rules
is
not going to be very effective because
an institute like the highways in uh
engineers institute i'm not going to be
listening to one councillor but what i
would ask to happen
is that this council
agrees
to start questioning the rules
they say that these rules are based on
their models and their formulas
and that those models and formulas are
tried and tested
the problem is that there is a
difference between the theory and the
practice they are seeing the theory we
are seeing the practice there is a
problem with their formulas and their
models that they do now i think that
would be very very difficult to dispute
at the moment because we of what we are
actually seeing on the ground so i would
ask that we as a council
agree
to start
questioning the rules at the roots if we
as a council get together and start
questioning is people are going to start
taking notice and they are going to
start questioning their own standards if
we don't do that we're just going to get
more of the same
thank you chairman councillor eves thank
you very much that is the finish of the
13 minutes i will now ask council ward
to summarize please
very briefly
can i raise a point of order please
i just want some clarification on this
we've been told there's a motion for no
further action now the options given
taking the action requested in the
petition
not taking the action requested for
reasons put forward in the debate or
commissioning further investigation
well unfortunately the motion was put
before we had a debate so how can we
decide
not to take action requested for reasons
put forward in a debate when the debate
was not allowed which to my mind is
effectively pre-determination of the
decision um can i have some clarity
please
council mrs wesley the debate started at
the minute that council ward
um uh began to speak um
and we've got 15 minutes from that time
which is now
nearly up i shall ask council wall to
summarise please
thank you chairman
yeah i do empathize with a lot of the
items that have been risen
with regard to highways and various
things like that
but i mean we have to recognize the
council is now preparing a new local
plan
and the work in assumptions for the
annual rate of housing delivery required
for the new plan period to 2037 which
may or may not be open to challenge this
takes into consideration the the items
raised with regard to highways and
things like that which we'll look at
but are based on nationally
prepared housing projections and a
standard methodology given to local
authorities by the government all
options of which will be seriously
considered but in the meantime i again
propose that there'll be no further
action and we continue on the route
delivering our local plan thank you
council steptoe would like to come back
thank you chairman
yes i i will affirm that uh i second the
motion but i will just add that in
my voter chairman it's been established
previously that although the sector may
reserve the right to speak they have no
right to speak over and above other
councillors thank you i'll leave you
with that chairman that's fine thank you
on the point of order chairman remover
motion to amend the
motion as put that we take no further
action and in the words of or the
paraphrase words of arthur dent from the
hitchhiker's guide to the galaxy we
unput this report in a finer cabinet in
the basement of this building thank
you mr james you have one minute to
further some up if you'd like to say
anything more thank you
yeah but personally i think it's a
disgrace that our our concerns aren't
being recognized and
from what council ward said
i think it's a disgrace that our
concerns aren't being recognized by this
council
to have a 15-minute debate on such an
important issue
is a joke i think the council award has
agreed to a public meeting then
a
venue
you said you were happy to have a public
meeting
do we get any time frame on that
um that will come out in the report you
i would suggest
is that you finished
yeah nothing else to say thank you mr
james members we have a motion moved by
council warden seconded by council
steptoe is that agreed members
they'll be recorded vote members
counsellor mrs barton
councillor burton
councillor mrs butcher
councillor canal
councillor carter
councillor mrs carter
councillor catmore paul
councillor dre
fall
councillor f day
four
councillor reeves
councillor mrs gooding
councillor hazelwood
councillor
against
councillor mrs hoy
councillor mr hoy
councillor hudson
councillor yuanu
councillor lucas gill
councillor mrs lumley
councillor mrs mason
council mrs mcpherson
councillor merrick
councillor newport
councillor mrs pavlin
councillor mrs rowe
counselor mrs shaw
councillor mr shaw
councillor smith
councillor sparing
councillor stanley
councillor steptoe
councillor ward
councillor webb
counselor mrs weston
councillor wilkinson against
councillor williams
councillor wilson against
four
members there were 24 votes for 13
against on one abstention
and therefore the motion is passed thank
you very much
mr james you will receive a written copy
of the council's response
to your petition the copy will also be
uploaded onto the council's website
members of the public you are more than
welcome to stay for the remaining
business but you'd like to leave please
do so by either by the door at the back
of the chamber or the right hand side
which will take you outside to the side
of the building or through the door to
the front of the chamber thank you
absolutely
um
because they missed it
it's just an excuse to stand
i remember coming into the campus
members
i will now take item 13 on the agenda
setting the council tax 2020 to 21
uh council steptoe
thank you jim
german this is my first budget as leader
of the conservative administration
the budget pressures under which local
government rates remain significant
and this
authority continues to look closely at
opportunities to make efficient savings
and generate new sources of revenue
this is not only
this is not only in response to the
removal of government grants but also to
the deal to deal with significant cost
increases arising from inflationary
and demographic pressures
looking to the future
we have refreshed our business plan for
the period 2020-23
in parallel with the
prep
in parallel with the preparation of the
medium-term financial strategy
so that the two align
the business plan sets out the high
level priorities that the council will
work towards over the medium term
this will incorporate the council's plan
to deliver an
exciting asset program
which aims to maximize the value of the
council's key strategic sites
and its connect and cultural
transformation program
to ensure members staff can operate as
21st century public servants
and improve our digital interface with
residents
our priorities are set out
in the refreshed business plan
are being financially sustainable
use only intervention to manage demand
on our service but sorry i'll say it
again use early intervention to manage
demand on our services
maximize our assets
and enable communities
despite the challenges faced we have
continued to deliver excellent services
to our residents
and our achievements in the past year
include
although not exclusively
being placed in the seventh have been
placed seventh in the league for
recycling out of more than 350
local authorities across england
continuing reduction number of homeless
households being placed
in
out of our district emergency temporary
accommodation
maintaining unqualified set of financial
accounts and value for money option
from our external holders
and valiant plans for 125 000 revamp of
three players
undertaking control of pollution act
works during the recent railway bridge
works in hall road
restoring electric
charges
in five of our council car parks one of
them right just outside our door here
obtaining a 10 000 pound lottery grant
to create an online
cgi tour of the hms beagle
partnering with chess that's the
church's homeless energy support support
scheme
to relieve homeless
and related hardship
launching the open doors project in
rochford town square which is in the old
king's head pub and i would recommend
members if you are in there please pop
in and have a look
continuing to provide
local businesses with advice and support
including hosting various business
breakfasts
being nominated as finalists for the old
house
in rochford and the rayleigh windmill
here in raleigh obviously
in the essex wedding awards 2020
category for historic wedding venue of
the year
producing a free cookbook and videos to
help residents cut back on food waste
following a careful management plan
sorry
following a perfect
following a careful management plan
populations of health rare care
butterflies
having thriving in hopley woods
so i got a bit tongue tied there
having a responsible as a responsible
council we continue to look at areas
where costs can be reduced
or income generated
however in 2020 there is a need to
increase the council tax by 2.15
to help fund the financial pressures
that the district is currently facing
this equates to an increase of 10 p
per household per week
on a band d property
the pros proposal is set out is set
proposedly set rockford district
council's tax for bandy property at 235
pound 26 p per year
the breakdown of the annual tax for
bandy property would be
essex county council
1204 pound and 92 p
essex count county council social care
levy
116 pound 19 pence
essex county
fire and rescue 73 pound 89
essex police fire and crime commissioner
198.63
the average town stroke parish council
51 74
and rochefort district council
235.26
the total average tax for bandy property
for 2020-21
would be
1880 pound and 63 pence
an increase
of 65 pound 81 approximately
3.63 percent
in conclusion
all those that
although these are still difficult
financial times
rochefort district council remains
committed to providing election service
to our residents and partners
with this in mind we will be doing all
we can to deliver innovative and high
quality services
chairman i commend the
lottery district council council tax for
members approval
and i make that as a proposal
thank you thank you council steptoe
council stepped up are you a second
officer
councillor smith
oh sorry
thank you thank you
apologies countersmith
councillor mrs mason
thank you mr chairman i think we all
appreciate the amount of work that goes
into financial planning
we all financial plan we do it in our
own homes we have our own budgets
and we are prudent with those budgets
generally people try not to overspend
and not to get into debt
and this council so far
has not got into
however
debt
prudent budget
is spending what's needed
not necessarily what's wanted
and there are two
variations upon this
i must admit
i have grave reservations
about approving a budget
where it includes
a new discretionary fund reserve of 50
000 pounds
for the leader
to dispense with and we have no
knowledge as of yet
how
that is a concern the concern also
that we always go for the maximum
2.15 percent
why do we do that
and
the leader has said
it's 10 pound a week yeah it's 10 p a
week
if you haven't got tempe
it's a lot but it's not tempe a week
because we add on the other taxes and as
has been noted it's 65 pounds
65 pounds from a tight budget and a lot
of our residents are on restricted
budgets is a lot of money
and that is on van d
and i don't believe that we have the
majority of our houses on bandy i
suspect they're higher and i suspect the
impact on our residents will be higher
so i remain concerned especially against
the maximum increase and i'm sure there
are items within this that we could
have made the increase more modest for
our residents thank you
council wilkinson
thank you chairman um i'd like to make
two points um the first is following on
from something council mrs mason has
just said about prudent financial
planning that we all do as homeowners
and
we all look and there are plenty of
sites out there to help us to do so um
for cheaper ways of obtaining the
services that we use at home
um whatever that may be we're always
doing it every year it comes up for
review and i'm sure everybody in this
chamber does it
um so i would therefore ask the question
because i don't know the answer is do we
do that no i know we are linked into
contracts i understand that
how are those contractors contracts
dealt with
and when are they up for renewal and are
we seeking
to try and offset some of our
uh gaps that we're trying to fund by
actually getting cheaper contracts
that's the first point i'd like to make
and the second point
is following on again from this budget
that um i too have reservations
something i've mentioned um last week's
full council meeting where we've
discussed the budget that's something
that i've mentioned an email since
is that i note that the council
in october
gave authority for
the portfolio holder for environment to
look for environment for communities
rather to form a working group to look
at cctv following on from my motion for
caesar tv
that authority told us to report back
within nine months that nine months
chairman is july which is only three
months into that the next financial year
yet not a penny
has been set aside in the capital budget
at all
for cctv
and
a few months prior to that
um we also agreed to send uh to start
looking at carbon neutrality which is
actually probably even more an important
issue and not a penny has been set aside
for that either and i i too as council
ms mason has issued less concerns i too
have concerns how we can ratify a budget
that doesn't have everything considered
within it thank you chairman
thank you chair um i would just say that
the the budget was already agreed at the
meeting last week so this this report is
purely about setting the council tax
level which is associated with the
budget which was agreed
last week but if there's any particular
questions i'm happy to take them outside
of this meet thank you
right um councillor mr hoy
thank you chairman
i think yes we are aware it's on the the
um setting the council
tax however obviously the council tax
was effectively set by setting the
budget last week and everything around
the budget pertains to the council tax
um i can't agree to a 2.5 increase 67
000 pounds he's going to straight to
reserves
with for no reason
um that's half the increase
approximately the other half is smoke
and mirrors as far as i'm concerned
again to agree with council wilkinson
there are two working groups none of
which have provisions within the budget
which pertains to the council tax if for
instance the council tax 67 67 000
pounds going to reserves may have been
allocated 50 50 to cctv and the 2030
working group i could understand that
but it isn't it's put to general
reserves we should be looking further
ahead and we are failing to do so
um
with regards to the 50 000 pound which
is also relevant because this budget
funds it
i've requested um
confirmation what this for i understand
that mr stratton will be sending at the
end of this week the details of that
however um
perhaps the leader could confirm if um
has been stated on social media by
conservative councillor that this will
be available for the use of
all councillors if they request it to
the leader i'll will not be supporting
the budget thank you
sorry
councillor stanley
thank you chairman
um
i'd like to begin uh as you can see from
the public gallery
the residents are concerned about the
council
and how it's been run to the benefit of
the residents
in the council tax and other things
to this
i mean all the residents not just those
that are represented by conservatives
but represented by
other parties and wall councillors
as it is well known that some of our
councillors are not being involved in
actions taken by the council and
therefore the residents views
of what we represent are not being heard
or taken into account or many projects
we have heard from the leader who
initially would like
contact with other members of the
council not just his own
unfortunately we have heard that this
has not been acceptable
my question to the leader is is this
going to change in the future so that
all of the residents will be heard
through their wall councillors
this request considers
with the peer review to bring the
minority into the consultation with the
council
i do find that over the past five years
a more than 1.5 million has been wasted
with projects
that really have not been fulfilled
i've heard that a considerable amount in
the council's funds
has been earmarked
for other usages
i'm not sure if we have been told of
these but nevertheless there are
projects which we need to be prioritized
sooner rather than later
these funds have been collected from the
residents
and should be used for the residents
thank you chairman thank you
council stanley
we had two meetings to discuss the
budget
where all councillors were invited and
only two members of the minority parties
turned up to the second meeting
members i don't see anybody else
indicating they wish to speak
um i shall therefore if you could turn
to page 10 on the recommendations are
set out sorry turn to the 10
recommendations that are set out on page
13.3 of the report
i will go through the recommendations in
turn
in line with the council procedural 17.3
set out on page 4.15 of the constitution
i would ask for a show of hands for each
recommendation
recommendation 1 is set out on page 13.3
of the report he's had agreed members
yes sorry show of hands
those four
against
any abstentions
that member has been approved
recommendation 2 is sat out on page 13.3
of the report
those in favor please indicate
those against
any abstentions
that members have been approved
recommendation 3 is set out on page 13.3
of the report is that is
all those in favor members
any against
any abstentions
that's been approved members
recommendation for assad held on page
13.3 of the report those in favor
those against
any extensions
that has been agreed members
recommendation 5 has set out on page
13.3 of the report
those in favor
those against
may my vote be recorded against please
chairman yes dude
thank you
anybody else
any abstentions
sorry can those who want their votes
recorded please put their hands up again
any abstentions
thank you
that members have been approved
recommendation 6 set out on page 13.3 of
the report those in favor
those against
that members has been approved
recommendation 8 on page 13.3 report
those in favor
those against
any attentions
that's been approved members
recommendation nine also on page 13.3 of
the report
those in favor
those against
any abstentions
that members again has been approved
um lastly recommendation 10 also on page
13.3 of the report those in favor
those against
any extensions
thank you members that again has been
proved thank you very much
the motions have been improved approved
to that includes item 13 members
are now gone to item seven
uh sorry i item seven agenda item
fourteen local council tax support
scheme twenty twenty twenty one
council smith will introduce this item
thank you chairman i think there'll be
more or there have been more
controversial things on the agenda than
than this item um this uh scheme
originally came about in 2013
it's been much talked about year on year
and uh there are no major changes apart
from an inflationary increase this is a
good scheme it includes a hardship fund
and i moved the recommendation on 8.1
and 8.2
thank you councillor smith councilman uh
hudson i'll be pretty quick in that
motion thank you councillor hudson
any questions members council mr hoy
thank you chairman i think everyone
should be used to my now speaking on
this every year actually um i still do
not agree that
on page 64. it's actually 14.67 of the
report um
i'm not sure item well 29 a1
top of the page on itunes 14
appendix one and it refers to
um
on the previous page you have minimum
income floor and this relates to
self-employed people and there's an
assumption within the plan that
self-employed people will be working 35
hours a week at the minimum wage i've
disagreed with this every year it's been
put forward for obvious reasons because
not every self-employed person
will get the minimum wage they're not
governed by the minimum wage wage law
they they can earn a pound an hour and
that's legal um
and this is my problem with the report
so therefore i'm proposing a motion that
29
when a
8.1 is removed from page 64 the actual
report page
14.667 of our report i don't know if i
have a second
thank you council hawkwood yes
that's my second uh councillor hoy's
amendment thank you
we will um therefore debate the
amendment any members wish to have any
questions on that amendment please
would you have an interest as a
self-employed person i'm not
self-employed no chairman okay thank you
for clarity
i work for a company owned by my wife
thank you okay
councillor fd did you wish to indicate
we should speak
i'm actually self-employed i don't know
if i can conflict or not
okay council hawkway
thank you chairman for clarity i am
self-employed i don't think that that
prevents me from participating in this
debate or in voting for this amendment
thank you
councillor
thank you um can i just ask councillor
smith the the data that council ahoy is
disagreeing with
why is that data like presented in that
format in the
in the report is that something that we
are guided to do is it something that
we've chosen to do
what is there a reason behind that
the technical question
um
i would just say that um
the scheme has been prepared in
consultation with an independent um
specialist who's provided advice on the
scheme and it's consistent with um a
number of schemes both across the essex
area and and nationally the the
rationale behind having a minimum wage
and a minimum number out of hours is to
provide sort of parity and fairness in
terms of how um individual applicants
are assessed against those that are
not self-employed so it is to provide a
sort of a baseline of parity
in terms of assessment
thank you councillor wilkinson thank you
very briefly and question for um naomi
if you wouldn't mind um with that in
mind are you able to indicate what
impact if any would have if we were to
remove that paragraph
um i'm afraid i wouldn't have that data
to hand and it's possible i could that
we may be able to
run some
figures to provide some sort of
financial assessment of the impact that
would have on nasa's authority but um i
think safe to say it would obviously
have a financial impact and the scheme
has to be contained within um
the sort of financial parameters which
were when the government introduced the
scheme in 2013 which provided a
reduction in the total funding available
of 10 so the scheme is designed to be
cross-neutral as a council and and to
provide fairness and parity to all those
um that may be eligible for the scheme
but um in terms of specifics i'd have to
take that away
any other questions members council
newport
thank you chairman um
yeah i will be supporting a councillor
hoy's amendment because i don't think
that
with the increase in numbers of
self-employed people
in our district i don't think we should
be penalizing them
at a point in time where possibly they
need our help
any other questions on council hawaii's
amended emotion please you know
councilory can i ask that you uh read
out again or explain again your amended
motion for clarity
thank you chairman sir not a remaining
motion it's a motion
um
under
29 29.0 that we remove
paragraph 29a.1
and the reference to the
the substituted amount of 35 hours per
week multiplied by the natural living
wage removes the entire pair of roth
thank you
thank you
members i don't see anybody else
indicating never to speak on that i
shall take a vote those in favor of the
um motion please demanded motion
those against
any abstentions
that members have has failed thank you
very much
um
we shall now go back to the original
motion as proposed by counter smith and
and seconded by councillor hudson
any other questions on that members
no
in that case members
there are
two recommendations i said on one's
recommendation one is set on page sent
out on page 14.2 of the report
can i have a show of hands please
in favor
against
abstentions
that members
that members has been passed
underneath chairman
[Music]
okay
members recommendation to us
on page 14.3 of the report
he's had agreed members i'll take a show
of hands this time
those against
this would be taking recommendation to
numbers on the previous one i can let
you have the numbers
no
sorry it wasn't a recorded vote so sorry
i did correct my wording i
i said recorded and then i said sorry i
mean noted thank you okay
your your vote will be noted then cows
are high
sorry sorry chairman
as in at the previous meeting last week
some of the votes were noted in the
minutes that's what i was requesting
that the notes be yes the vote be noted
in the minutes by yeah i misspoke and
use the word recorded and then i use the
word noted
afterwards but you may not have heard
that
okay
if
if you want the numbers noted it has to
be recorded vote counselors
that was last week i'm afraid
right
mr chairman as a point of order when
you're
if we are taking a vote
we're not asking for a recorded vote
we're asking for the numbers for the
numbers against and the numbers that
abstain that is perfectly normal it has
been done in this council for years and
i don't think you can just say we can't
have that
right he says in the constitution that
the vote will be a show by show of hands
unless a recorded vote is demanded under
rule 17.4
the chairman will take the vote by a
show of hands
it doesn't state that you can't count
those hands
surely the officer counts the hands to
know if the vote is passed or not and if
they're counting them can they not
disclose that information i don't
believe this democracy it's not
it's a it's a majority vote by show of
hands and it was clearly
uh in favor of the recommendation
sorry
the votes have been taken members i
should move on to recommendation two
i said on page 14.3 of the report
is that agreed members
if we can't count them then we're going
to have to have recorded votes on
everything i i would ask the legal
officer to consider
this situation because this is farcical
i agree
we're actually just
following over
a stand which was made last week in this
chamber where
votes were noted and announced
you can't change the rules week on week
without good reason
and for a matter of clarity mr chairman
do excuse me but this has been going on
for years as far back as chris black's
time this used to happen and i'm sure
council cut more will recall that it's
never been disallowed before so what
undemocratic reasons have we got
there'll be a recorded vote members on
recommendation too
council mrs belton
[Music]
councillor burton
councillor mrs butcher
councillor canal
councillor carter
councillor mrs carter
councillor catmore
councillor dre four
councillor fd
stein
councillor reeves
councillor mrs gooding
councillor hazelwood
councillor hookway
against
councillor mrs hoy
councillor mr hoy
councillor hudson
councillor yuanu
councillor lucas gill
councillor mrs lumley
councillor mrs mason
counselor mrs mcpherson
councillor merrick
counselor newport
cancer mrs pavlin
councillor mrs rowe
cancer mrs shaw
cancer mr shaw
councillor smith
councillor spuring
councillor stanley
councillor steptoe
council award
councillor webb
councillor mrs weston
councillor wilkinson
councillor williams
councillor wilson
cancer water
remember there were 29 votes four five
against and four abstentions
the motion is therefore approved members
that concludes item 14. i shall now have
gone to item 15 the pay policy statement
2020
2021 mr strutton managing director will
introduce this report
chairman thank you uh very little to say
this sets out the council's pay policy
statement uh in accordance with the
requirements of the localism act uh
2011.
any questions members
counselor mrs uh mrs mason
thank you mr chairman i seem to be
taking up a look your time this evening
um this is merely a question which i'm
hoping the um which i'd like some
clarification on and i am hoping that
the
managing director will be able to
clarify this on appendix 1.3.9
it says the council does not apply
performance related pay or bonuses
however
does a po a bonus for attendance not
constitute performance related payment
as is detailed in 4.1 this just seems to
be a contradiction in that report but
i'd like to clarify that
thank you
well
chairman the council does not in in
principle apply uh performance related
pay or bonuses
uh the reference i believe to is to a
small payment that is made in relation
to attendance and attendance allowance
of
officers of the council
thank you mr chairman i wasn't aware it
was a small payment because the amount
isn't noted um but i accept that it's
not considered a bonus then in that case
thank you
i cannot see anybody else indicating
they wish to speak
mr speaker
um yeah just to clarify that the main
point of the report is that we are
obviously opted into the national sort
of pay terms and conditions so we don't
have a locally set performance related
pay scheme but obviously on top of that
we have a locally agreed discretionary
scheme which does provide us an amount
for us um a small bonus for exemplary
attendance and by council officers but
that is a locally set discretionary
policy which we choose to apply locally
but but in the main our salary scales
are set with it in line with the
national terms and conditions
thank you
councillor wilkinson so very briefly um
i may misunderstood here but um i'm sure
mr scotland said that you don't have
bonuses naomi's just used the word bonus
um i'm not sure which it is uh if money
is paid to people for attendance i'm not
suggesting i have an issue with that but
i'd just like some clarity to the
parameters for that are we saying it's
like a well done you've attended you
haven't had a sick day or whatever it
happens to be which is a bonus in my
eyes and it clearly is the words that
have been used by naomi
which seems to be odds with what the
md's
okay um well i can provide um
counsellors with the um wording of the
um policy um which we have which is
called um a staff award an attendance
award which is awarded for 100
attendance for a six monthly period um
yeah um officers are eligible to receive
50 pounds if they um have a 100
attendance over a six-month period so
that that so perhaps i misspoke when i
use the word bonus but that is the
nature of the scheme thank you
thank you
members no other members are indicating
they wish to speak i shall therefore
it takes recommendations set out on page
15.2 of the report a paragraph 7.1
it is a proposal that council resolves
that the pay policy statement 2020 21 be
adopted is that agreed members by show
of hands
those against
any potentials
that members has been approved thank you
that
concludes item 15 item 16 appointment of
independent persons and parish
representatives to the standards
committee
angel or assistant director will
introduce this report
thank you chairman
the report is to seek approval to
appoint three independent persons to the
standards committee and to endorse three
parish councils uh to the standards
committee
the report seeks
that the authorities dedicated to me as
a monitoring officer to recruit the
independent persons to the posts in
accordance with the criteria set down in
the localism act
in relation to the parish councils once
agreed the richard hundred association
will be approached for their nominations
these councils are not voting members of
the standards committee but as the
district council is responsible for
dealing with the parish council's
complaints their views were uh will be
and are taken into account on any
standards matter relating or affecting
the parish councils so chairman this
report seeks the approval of the
recommendations put forward
on page
16.2 of the report
any questions members
no
and there are two recommendations
recommendation one is set on page 16.2
of the report is that agreed members
recommendation two
also sent out on page 16.2 of the report
is our agreed members
thank you members that
includes this item 16.
and then go back to items
item six
remember questions on notice
i have
if i can ask you to take your places now
please
ah
members i'll now take item six on the
agenda members questions on notice of
which there are three
question one has been raised by council
wilkinson and is for the portfolio
holder for planning
council wilkinson would you please ask
ask you to present i could ask you to
print your question to the committee
please thank you chairman could have
portfolio holder for planning please
explain what actions rocha district
council is taking to challenge the views
of the county's highways department
about the impact of new development in
the highways network which often seems
to be odds with those district
councillors
council awards can i ask you to respond
to that please
thank you
yeah thank you chairman
i absolutely fully
fully share members frustrations in
regards to this
whereby highways decisions are seemingly
at odds with those artistic councillors
which then asks the questions what are
our options
as essex highways are a statutory
consultant
the options become narrower
i felt the best way forward
was to see if we could organize training
sessions for members regarding the role
essex highways takes as a statutory
consultant for planning applications
essex highways officers would be present
to field any questions that members may
have
and i would strongly encourage members
to attend to assist them in gaining a
better understanding of what is
considered by highways in an application
and how they arrive at their conclusions
i hope this will go some way
towards addressing members concerns
as an additional thought
should members have specific issues that
they wish to raise about any specific
planning application i would encourage
them to contact the case officer who
will be able to raise these matters at
the recently established weekly meetings
between the local essex highway officer
and our planning officers where any
concerns where possible can be resolved
to conclude
myself as portfolio holder for planning
councillor mike steptoe as leader
working in conjunction with the essex
county council portfolio holder for
infrastructure councillor kevin bentley
together with help initiated by mark
francois has resulted upon essex
establishing the developers forum
now established this is intended to
coordinate the activities
activities of putting new infrastructure
in place in the course of planned
development
as well as the updating of existing
infrastructure excluding emergency
repairs
there is no doubt that any road works
will be disruptive but we are trying to
establish good cooperative working
practices to minimize the disruption to
residents i hope that helps thank you
council award council wilkinson do you
have a supplementary question that you
wish to ask which must be linked to the
original question or the response given
by council award
i i don't have a question well i suppose
i do have a question i'd just like to
come back if i may
um
thank you for the answer council award
what i would say is that
it sounds from what you're saying and
i'm not trying to knock the idea because
i embrace any training that is offered
by the council so thank you for that but
it does sound as though that is us being
taught what county are doing as opposed
to us challenging county which is really
what my question was um i and
the leader is aware of this as well as
council alumni um i've actually
contacted councillor bentley myself as a
lowly backbencher
regarding the highways department and
challenging their views now
if i can do that then surely as a
council
with respect you can do that
would you like to come back council
award
yes thank you very much chairman um as
far as challenging i i've asked our
officers to actually challenge and go
back and and make a challenge um in
regards to
any decision that comes from highways if
they feel that there is an issue but i
think it's actually important to
understand how highways actually arrive
at their decisions hence the idea of
this interaction so we can actually have
this training session with highways
officers to actually even challenge them
there and there it gives a good
opportunity for us to understand exactly
where they are coming from in their
decisions how they make those decisions
and i think it may further somewhere
what you are asking or what we all want
where quite often a lot of things are at
odds thank you thank you council award
council question two has been raised by
council mr hoy and is for the portfolio
holder for planning
council mr hoy can i ask you to present
your question to the council thank you
chairman
um can the portfolio holder for planning
please confirm that they have full
confidence in this council's planning
policies and that it should be at the
discretion of councillors whether those
policies should not be applied to
certain planning applications
council award can i actually respond to
that please
thank you chairman uh what an excellent
question
councillors i believe should of course
use their discretion
when determining planning applications
as long as they are basing their
decisions on our current planning
policies regarding recognizing that the
weight and interpretation given to a
specific policy will vary when
considering the merits of an individual
application
however further to the council's own
policies particular consideration should
be given to the national planning policy
framework and any emerging case law from
recent planning applications
therefore i not only have full
confidence in the council's planning
policies more importantly i have full
confidence in our members who adjudicate
on applications together with their
ability to resolve a reasoned balanced
judgment on the merits of each
individual case
thank you thank you council award
council mr hoy do you have a
supplementary question which must be
linked to the original question or
council wars response thank you chairman
um based on your answer uh council can
you confirm why you think there is such
a discrepancy between what what members
believe is a an acceptable discrepancy
and what officers believe is an
acceptable discrepancy council award
as i said it is
about
actually looking at how you weigh
something
where where you have a policy and how
that policy is weighed
again different weight is given to
different interpretations of it and
again if there is a final adjudication
on anything is then down to the
inspector because if it goes to appeal
he is the final arbiter of everything
thank you
thank you council award
question three has also been raised by
council mr hoy and is for the leader of
the council council hey can i ask you to
present your question please
thank you chairman i think i wrote this
one without punctuation but i believe it
is understandable
with the leader of the council please
confirm to members how the workings of
the review working group 2030 are
feeding back into the council leadership
on progress they are making and how the
executive are planning for the future
whilst keeping in mind the possible
results of the working group 2030 and
that how that may affect future plans
council step 2.
thank you chairman thank you councillor
for the question
and please bear with me the answer is a
little bit of a tongue twister so please
bear with me
the working group has the support of the
assistant director place and environment
and overview and scrutiny officer
the officers had
have a two-way dialogue with the
relevant members of staff within the
council and the other authorities to
gather information to be provided to the
working group
this information has come either in the
form of briefing notes or
as with the case with the council
council's assets
the assistant director assets and
commercial and portfolio holder for
enterprise have attended meetings as the
working group to discuss and answer
questions on the issues
the portfolio holder for environment has
intended the working group
as an observer and is kept up to date
with the thoughts of the group
in addition the assistant director place
environment
has been has been briefing the
leadership team on the developments from
the working group to ensure that the
outcomes from the working group are
understood
the findings of the working group are to
be brought back to the review committee
in march
and should and should reckon
and should recommendations be resolved
will be taken forward to council in
april for approval thank you council
steptoe councillor mr hoy do you have a
supplementary question which must be
linked to your original question or the
response given by councillor steptoe oh
yes thank you chairman um and thank you
um council steptoe for the the full
response um
could you um
based on your your answer clearly the
information is being led fed back into
the leadership team at all levels
um
can you say as leave that you're
confident that
this information
is
is helping
officers and
the executive make decisions now such as
on
say the freight house
that
will make mean it will be
compliant with whatever 20 the
2030 working group
may
suggest
cancer step 2
thank you chairman simple answer
yes thank you council step two
okay members at ten o'clock the meeting
will have lasted two and a half hours uh
that is to prescribe for meetings of the
council we still have a number of items
still to get through it will be good to
try and get through all of the remaining
business if at all possible i move
motion without notice 9n set out on page
4.23 of the constitution and continue
this meeting beyond two and a half hours
do i have a seconder
thank you counselor cut more
is that agreed members
show of hands all in favor
those against
any abstentions
right
that is agreed members in liberal
council procedure rule 17.3 so on page
4.15 of the constitution
oh sorry i've already done that i
apologize
we will continue after 10 o'clock then
members
council and mrs mcpherson
i would suggest we review it again at 10
30 to see how we are okay
right i shall take item seven then
agenda
item no where are you
sorry item six of the agenda
item seven of the agenda business from
last council
members there are none
councillor mrs mason
thank you mr chairman you'll recall at
the last meeting we were concerned about
the lack of
resident engagement that the council
based its uh budget on 222 replies out
of 80 odd thousand
and the leader advised that he would
discuss the issue and i'm reading from
the minutes of improving public
engagement in the budget process with
officers and portfolio holders and would
report back to members on this issue is
he in a position to report back
answer mr steptoe would you like to
respond to german uh no not as of yet
we've been concentrating on other
matters uh between times but i will get
a report back to members thank you uh
councillor steptoe
councillors i shall take item eight on
the
agenda minutes of the executive and
committee meetings held between the
period 4th of december 2019 to the 4th
of february 2019.
do you note these members
thank you agenda item nine
reports from the executive and
committees to council
the report the standards committee on
the member training working group
councillor mrs mcpherson chairman of
stands committee will introduce this
item
thank you chairman i think everybody'd
be happy if i keep this brief um in
december we had a very robust uh um
discussion and debate around the
membership of the group and in mr hoy's
own words um
the membership had been somewhat cobbled
by the decision made in december 2017
it was actually unanimous
as
a group of
the committee that we amend that and
that is there on bullet point um one two
three under 1.2 and the recommendation
is over the page uh 2.1
thank you chairman do you have a
secondary counselor mrs mcpherson
okay counselor mrs mason
is are you second in it counselor yeah
okay thank you
the members i shall
put it any questions at all first of all
no questions
uh the recommendation then is that the
proposed pro council resolves that the
composition of the member training
working group be decided and constituted
by the standards committee starting from
the next municipal year onwards is that
agreed members thank you
can i just ask for some clarification mr
chairman on a point of order you've
you've said that we can't have counting
because for some reason we can't it's a
new rule but you've said that decisions
will be made on a show of hands now
we're not even going that far
i'm really at a loss to know how this is
being administered
members i shall go back to that
recommendation
for those all those who agree the
recommendation please indicate by show
of hands
it is unanimous thank you members
right item 10 uh members report on
urgent business
remember there are none
item 11 report on the leader of the
workers the executive
cancer slepto
thank you chairman
just before i give my report i would
just like to pick up an appointment that
councillor stanley made
earlier on
i go to great lengths
to
invite mem members of all persuasions
across the chamber
to attend various meetings budget
meetings
working parties etc and in actual fact
i did create the situation and this was
agreed at council a little while ago
that members could come along and ask
questions at the executive
to date i've not had anybody come
forward for that so perhaps i can remind
members that that facility is now
available
chairman this is the fourth ordinary
council meeting of the 2019-20
municipal year
and i well would like to welcome all
members
since the meeting on the 17th of
december the executive has met once
during which considerations included
noting the quarter 3 20 1920 revenue
budget and capital position
approving the outline business case for
the connect cultural and transformation
program and including agreement that
that program be designated as a gold
project and the funding of 293 000 pound
it could be created from the 2019
sorry the 2019 stroke 20
underspend
agreement to lease the council owned
land to rayleigh sports
sorry raleigh town sports and social
club for the use of their sports ground
and social use for a period of 28 years
agree the disposal of the freehold
interest of land at cagefield road
stanbridge
other matters that my executive
colleagues and i have
dealt with include
agreeing to the lease
agreeing to lease the council-owned
asset known as clemens hall pavilion
to s east essex hackspace community
interest company for a period of seven
years
agreeing to submit a formal response to
the castle point council's
2019 pre-submission local
plan consultation
with the within the
prescribed time period
as always chairman i will be happy to
take any questions from the members
in respect to the work of the executive
and i'm sure my executive colleagues
will be more than happy to contribute
where appropriate thank you council
steptoe council mr hoyer
thank you hopefully it's a very simple
one this time um i know term that
council steps i mentioned about the the
fact that we that all councillors now
now come to the executive and ask
questions i'm aware that he did stay
that was state that was changing however
i and i i apologize for missing this but
i didn't see where it came out to us as
a change in the constitution or a change
by no city council i just haven't seen
it i've read as you might be aware that
i'm a bit of a nerd and i do like
reading constitutions and i can quote
from our constitution quite well and i
cannot recall it being changed for this
purpose um if it isn't being changed on
what basis
are members allowed to go to the
executive questions do they have been
noticed can they be asked at the meeting
without notice are follow-up questions
allowed can we have some clarity please
or and
chairman i see our legal officers as
he's quickly looking to see where it is
in the constitution perhaps uh
she can advise that
but
chairman yes there has been a change to
the constitution um it's on page 4.52 of
the constitution
questions are noticed at executive
meetings it sets out the um criteria for
members to attend those
just ask when that was changed please
because i can't remember it i can't
record it go through council can confirm
when it went through council please
22nd of october 2019.
thank you
yes
cash leaves
thank you chairman um i'd just like to
uh for the sake of clarity um on the
chairman's first comment about
opposition not engaging
make an observation on that that i think
the administration may not actually have
taken into account
one of the things that
we are quite keen to do on the
opposition benches here believe it or
not is actually to make a difference
that's why we've stand stood for
election
the fact is
that
certainly in the short tenure that our
leaders had so far
we've had
many many situations
where
the corporation has been completely
opposite
the first two council meetings that we
had
we brought me brought items to the
agenda
and the first one was completely
fascicled because it didn't come from
the administration
it was something that was vote that was
put a different motion in which was
exactly the same as the motion that i
put in but because it didn't come from
the administration it wasn't actually
carried through as we put through and
this has happened again and again
this i hope the opposite the
administration realized that this is a
frustration
that we on the opposition benches are
feeling more and more
and we are getting it again tonight
in uh some of the things that have been
put forward and i wouldn't mind betting
that in some of the motions on notice
that been put forward
by
members of the opposition tonight that
they don't go through as they've been
put through
as the um
they've been put in without an amendment
so as it does gives a little bit of
a
a boost to the administration
and um i'd just like to
acknowledge the fact that we would like
to be involved in fact i'm involved with
two
working groups i want to make a
difference that's why i stood for
election
but being constantly ignored
and put to one side
by procedural issues etc does get
disheartening on occasions and when we
are offered the chance of coming to be
part of the discussions or to listen to
these discussions we do begin to get a
feeling of why why bother
thank you council reeves
council newport
thank you chairman um just
following on from what councilor reeves
has just said
um
i became a group leader for lib dems
late last year um taking over from
council stanley
and during that time since
i've not received any communication from
the leader himself and i don't know
whether that's because i've pointed this
out recently there was an issue with
receiving emails from
councillor steptoe but i just you know
we have we haven't closed our doors to
being involved in anything within this
council thank you thank you councillor
newport
no other quick
okay
councillor mr hoy on a point of order
when this council approves changes the
constitution surely we're allowed to
know what the changes actually are that
there's no detail in the motion of the
22nd of october to say what the act he
just says it approves
the changes but there are no changes in
the minutes at all
sorry chairman
the
leaders report
is read out by the leader and the whole
purpose of this section is actually to
ask direct questions of the leader about
that report
here we are back debating the
constitution uh here we are back date uh
debating the role of the
minority parties uh so i just put that
to your chat thank you councillor
chairman in response to council hoy's uh
question i i recall that it was actually
a report before council
thank you
right members we'll now take
item
12 on the agenda motions on notice
members we have a total of seven motions
on notice the first motion
has
the first motion has been posed by
councillor webb and seconded by council
steptoe council webb
would you please summarize and speak on
your notion no to no motion on notice
please thank you chairman members
holocaust memorial day was a recent
reminder of the need to remain vigilant
against anti-semitism both at a national
and a local level
thankfully within the district
anti-semitism is currently not a
significant issue
with a few examples of offensive
graffiti that we have had being dealt
with extremely promptly
that said i would encourage us as a
council to adopt the international
holocaust remembrance alliance
working definition of anti-semitism as a
clear message
that anti-any anti-semitic behaviour
will not be tolerated
this definition has also been adopted by
the government and a number of other
local authorities
are now also adopting this definition
the secretary of state recently wrote to
us and asking us to adopt this
definition which i hope we would
endorse
so further to the secretary of state's
debt of the 15th of october 2019 to
council leaders
this council is asked to adopt the
international holocaust remembrance
alliance's definition of anti-semitism
are set out below
anti-semitism is a certain perception of
jews which may be expressed as hatred
towards jews
rhetorical and physical manifestations
of anti-semitism are directed towards
jewish or non-jewish individuals
and or their property
towards jewish community institutions
and religious
facilities
thank you chairman
council steptoe
thank you chairman i have pleasure in uh
second in this uh proposition are there
any questions members
counsellor mr hoyer
no questions as such but just so i'm
very happy to support this um motion i
think it's about time this council stop
to some of the anti-semitism that's been
happening in the district particularly
in rayleigh which i'm aware of and i'll
fully support this thank you thank you
our members we have a proposal and
secondary um can have a show of hands in
favor please
any against
any abstentions
thank you members that motion is agreed
the second motion has been proposed by
council mrs mason mrs mason council mrs
mason would you like to summarize and
speak on your motion of notice please
um
i think that the motion in a way speaks
for itself but what we've heard tonight
on many accounts actually
says why we're doing this minority
groups in this council and i don't i
don't like the term opposition we're not
opposing we're trying to work with the
team but we're finding that there's
not been possible not for many reasons
um opposition oppression whatever we're
not we're minority groups and as
councillors have said we
want the best interests and the best
result for this council and in doing so
we need to have a voice and particularly
a voice on the overview and scrutiny
committee which is the most important
committee
of
the this you know this council it is the
policeman it is it checks it helps
it oversees as the word says it overview
and scrutiny so the motion is that this
council
having received the observations of the
corporate peer challenge
and the identified need to strengthen
the scrutiny function and the inclusion
in the report that the minority
political groups do not feel
sufficiently engaged
address both these points by altering
the constitution as follows
and to alter the constitution prior to
annual council
so that the chair of the overview and
scrutiny committee
review committee be nominated
by the minority political groups and
independent members only
if no member of the minority political
groups accepts a nomination then and
only then will nominations be accepted
from any other member
this would not only encourage minority
political groups an independent member
engagement
and facilitate greater scrutiny if
minority political groups and
independent members
felt their views had some impact rather
than the current imposition that their
views are being ignored by the majority
political group
second
okay second that chairman i think i may
respond
hey councillor
thank you chairman
the rules around the chairmanship of
review committee were previously
approved by this council and is set down
in the constitution that it should be a
member from the opposition
that's lawful
motion put forward by councillor mrs
mason would be undemocratic in that it
excludes the members of my group
and that would be 27 members of this
council chairman
following the peer review feedback
report of the local
government association
it is recognised that there is a wider
piece of work to be carried out with
regards to the council's scrutiny
function
which the monitoring officer is
currently investigating
she will report back in due course as to
her findings and actions or
recommendations
i note what counselor mrs mason has said
about encouraging and engaging minority
groups and independent members but
revising the method as to how a chairman
is selected
does not achieve this to agree this
motion now would preempt any outcome of
the wider work
which is yet to be completed thank you
chairman
councillor
thank you chairman
since i was elected onto this council in
2014 the issue of how the chairman of
the review committee has been selected
has and remains a major irritation to
certain opposition members who believe
that they and only they should have the
power to elect a member to that position
such is their continued determination to
change the constitution so that this may
become the case
i have personally found myself
questioning the motives for such an
unnecessary change
for the benefit of everyone here this
evening and for absolute clarity i am
the current chair of the review
committee a position i've held since
2016.
until recently i was the only
politically independent counselor
elected to this council and it was felt
by the majority of the conservative
members that i was the most suitable to
hold that position bearing in mind my
political neutrality
this motion does indeed refer to the
recent corporate peer challenge which
contains the sentence the council also
needs to strengthen the scrutiny
function which members said does not
play a positive role in policy
development
this is an interesting yet disappointing
conclusion disappointing because from
what i can deduce neither myself as
chairman the overview and scrutiny
officer or members of the conservative
group who sit on that committee that i
have spoken to so far
none of us were invited to contribute to
this review
something i believe was the case when
the last review was carried out in 2012
interestingly at the same time because i
can therefore only assume that the
members who did participate were
ironically members of the opposition
parties who state that they do not feel
sufficiently engaged and whose input has
led to a conclusion that i believe has
been politically arrived at
this motion suggests to me that those
proposing it believe that the ability to
solely elect who chairs that committee
will somehow strengthen it
that is not the conclusion reached in
this report or the report made in 2012
and has not been suggested by those who
carried out the review at any time
interestingly when the last report was
carried out in 2012 when the very same
issue regarding the review committee was
highlighted
at that time in the immediate subsequent
years that followed the committee
was actually chaired by councillor mr
hoy elected by minority party members
and who now brings forward this motion
to full council
this motion claims that such a change to
the constitution would encourage
minority groups and independent member
engagement and facilitate greater
scrutiny if minority political groups
and independent members felt their views
had some impact rather than current
rather than the current impression that
their views are being ignored by the
majority political group
members
there will always be a majority
political group
more than likely to be conservative
regardless of who elects who to the
position of chairman of review
if the minority members believe that
they are being ignored
why do those same members believe that
by having the sole power to elected this
position the majority political group
will no longer ignore their views
something i don't agree
in my opinion we have a minority group
we have minority group members who have
chosen to isolate themselves and made
the often collective decision not to
engage with the rest of the council or
councillors
who do not volunteer to sit on working
groups where their independent strengths
and knowledge will be helpful and
greatly appreciated
yet choose to cry neglect and exclusion
at every given opportunity
i still question the real motives behind
this motion but i do know it's got
nothing to do with strengthening the
review committee or making my minority
members feel engaged when they
repeatedly choose not to engage with a
conservative led counsel
because of my current position should
this go to a vote i will be abstaining
thank you thank you council
council wilkinson
well thank you chairman i'm absolutely
gobsmacked to what i've just listened to
first things first i would like to put
on record um because there have been
several discussions about this that i do
feel
engaged
um that i have been approached by mr
cancer steptoe um and i have been
invited to be part of the
car park working group and i think he's
done that uh because i am an independent
member and because i'm not part of a
political group and i don't get a look
and otherwise having said that i am also
on other committees because other
members have been grateful enough uh to
give me their
their places the um licensing sub
committee being one of them
so
but i do understand the frustration that
is shared by members here because i did
voice in an email this week to the
managing director um that i feel as
though when we are in and i understand
how democracy works and it's a phrase
i've used this week a couple of times
but when there is one party domination
to the point that we have here is yes
you sit here and listen i'm sure you do
see him listen but with the exception of
some some members and there are some and
i do want to acknowledge there are some
members of your group who do vote with
us the vast majority don't and you
assume you're more than entitled to do
so
we do feel as though we're we're not
listening to the two motions that
council hawaii makes reference to his
own one and mine both of those were
taken from us both of those are now in
existence exactly what we wanted but
they've now got the the political twist
in it which was unnecessary i think
that's evidence of it what i've just
heard from councillor burton is without
words the most
unbelievable thing i thought the what
happened in july last year was unreal
what i've just heard from you is even
worse
we aren't engaged you disengage yourself
i i i've never known anybody on these
benches to completely ignore everybody
else on these on these benches i've
tried to engage with you enough times as
a ward counselor with you you ignore me
you know this is good this is beyond
belief
yeah i know it's clear
council wilkinson address the chair
please over time it was a personal
attack on us and i'm now returning it
chairman i will say nothing more than
this
that
this the it is
we are the the motion that's been put
forward this evening is not for us to
choose
the chair of the review committee that
is not what it says
we have put forward a motion or these
councils put forward a motion to
nominate it then goes to full council
for that person to be elected but what
we are having is
we we we voted for somebody we wanted
somebody and each year that person got
getting elected and the person that the
administration are choosing is being
elected and that's the point we're
saying it feels unfair and they should
be open to scrutiny thank you thank you
councillor wilkinson
does anybody else wish to speak on this
counselor mr hoy
yes so sharon hackout indicated i
thought you noticed me but obviously not
um
with regard to to date which i think i
must address because i think council
burton
has
mixed them up somehow um
when the previous
peer review came i did meet with them
and at that point i was not a member of
the review committee
after they left they increased the size
of the review committee and i became a
member
once we formed a group
of two people um i was at that point not
a chair um i believe
and i cannot remember for sure it was
either councillors lovely and then
certainly subsequently councillor mr
lumley who was chair after the peer
review at that time i only ever appeared
um chaired the um review committee
once and i checked it for approximately
10 months because i believe
councillor alumni was in it prior to me
and he had an extended stay because of a
think of a european election possibly so
i was only chair for about 10 months so
it's actually quite a short period i was
chair of
after that point
at that point when i was chair
i was
in some ways very undemocratically i'd
probably agree with this i was merely
chair because we
we were the largest
non we were the largest opposition group
and at that point it went to the a
member of the largest largest opposition
group and i'd probably agree that that
in itself is probably undemocratic and i
wouldn't argue with changing that
however the um
conservatives at that time decided to
change it
to
any member of the opposition group which
then allowed them
to
choose the person who would chair
the review committee
and that
is the problem we have we wouldn't have
any objection to another formulation of
it and i think this is the best
formulation we can come up with which
makes it more democratic than it used to
be
and certainly more democratic than it
currently is
i'm not going to make a personal attack
on casa burton he chairs the committee
perfectly finely i think he's very fair
to all members of it and i wouldn't say
he isn't and i'm very disappointed that
he's chosen to attack us
personally
on the way he
has however i think this motion
takes on board the changes that the
conservatives made to the constitution
prior to when i was on it and have made
their
changes much more democratic
much more democratic than they were and
much more democratic than they were when
i was first elected to the committee and
that's why i've seconded the motion and
will be supporting it thank you
councillor newport
[Music]
thank you chair um
on the subject of the peer
um review group
i did meet with the peer um team peer
review team
and it was very interesting first time
i've met with them
um
the
representative i spoke to was actually a
conservative councillor from elsewhere
in the country
he described our review committee as
having rubber teeth
his words um
and
i've i think even though i'm not on
review
i've
taken an active part in
a working group from review committee
the ict task group
and i'm very enthusiastic about that and
then
and
in fact i've requested further meetings
um to discuss that
so
i actually feel as if um
you know comments about us not engaging
um are probably
not very fair in a lot of ways
but i do think that
policing
um policing the police policing
themselves isn't a good idea and i think
that this change would be a positive
step to that
council hook way
thank you chairman it's just um
uh
a brief comment just to say that uh as i
understand uh the motion before us is
that uh
the opposition groups and independent
members are looking to nominate
someone to go before full council
so i can't see that
the uh the argument against this has
been undemocratic uh stands because it
then falls for the council to make a
decision about that nomination um so
there is democracy
uh elements in this uh in this uh motion
uh and i i i support it
thank you councilwood
members i see no
sorry counselor mrs mace oh sorry my
couch yeah
mrs mcpherson counselor mrs mcpherson
sorry joe
thank you chairman um just to do it
through yourself
there's been a lot of talk about
inclusion and engagement i was very
pleased to hear um council mr hoy's
comments around the chairman of scrutiny
and all of you i should say and i would
urge anybody who is listening to this
conversation to actually go and listen
to the audios of the review committee
everyone is included in that meeting
only recently we had
one of the subjects was to do with um
housing
and it was to do with the leasehold
scheme and one of our councillors here
councillors councillor mrs mason has a
lot of knowledge in that
i think most of us were in awe of her
knowledge and we were listening
and taking that on board and i believe
he may be the chair of that working
group is that correct it is
um
i object a little bit to the inclusion
comments um there are people here to my
right who will know that i have
personally called them up and asked them
to join working groups come to the
budget away days
um
the late wonderful councillor black
always used to come to the budget away
days because a good idea
is a good idea whoever puts it forward
and
what i also take umbrage about with this
inclusion is it's quite difficult
when you then go home and some of the
things that we have done such as set the
budget is ridiculed on one of the
political
pages and yet some of those people
haven't even engaged in it
so this is a two-way thing
i i call people up i try to get them to
engage but then
us
where we just killed and yet some people
haven't taken part in anything to do
with it thank you thank you
council mrs mason
i didn't expect
this at all because this was a motion
that was being positive and constructive
i'm
surprised that counselor burton's taken
it personally it wasn't meant personally
it wasn't meant as a criticism
and as an independent member councilor
burton probably isn't aware that a lot
of us sit on other committees and do
participate in quite a lot of other
working groups but it isn't personal so
it isn't an issue on that so this isn't
a criticism of counselor burton and i'm
upset that he's managed to take it that
way
what it is is a clear
if you like here we're going back to
where we were before we had difficulties
where
the minority groups felt excluded now
whether we're right or wrong in feeling
excluded i can't say but what i do know
is that's the feeling and it's a strong
feeling and this is trying to rectify
that feeling
and there's a gross misunderstanding
here that they that
you're not going to elect the chair
all we're saying is the nomination as it
used to be it used to always be as
councillor hoy has said
from the largest
opposition if you like group
and they always used to be and there was
never a problem until that was changed
by the administration since then there's
been a feeling of disengagement and a
lack of empowerment
and
i'm not saying this is deliberate but
whether it's deliberate or not it has
happened
and if you want to work
with us all and we want to work with you
that's what we're elected for
and we want you to participate
then you need to occasionally listen to
us and not take it as personal criticism
not taking it as a criticism against
um your party so i am concluding here
and um
so
it everyone will vote all i'm altering
is the nomination and can i ask that the
motion be put please mr chairman thank
you
thank you mrs uh councillor mrs mason
members i will uh
do you have you had a second or did you
miss mrs mason
right in the motion
it has been seconded
before
it was seconded or secondly
members i shall now uh
i should now ask members to vote on the
motion
uh those in favor please indicate
recording this four places
those against
any abstentions
one two
that motion has failed members thank you
very much
members as promised earlier it is now
coming up to 10 30 and i move without
notice uh 9n set out on page 42 4.23 of
the constitution and continue
this meeting i would suggest for another
half an hour we do have another five
motions to
visit
um
do i have a seconder yes
thank you councillor couple
he's had agreed members
yeah those can have a show of hands
please for those in favor
those against
any abstentions
that is carried i shall review the
situation again at the eleven o'clock
members
um sorry chairman point of all that um
i'm afraid myself and mrs
castleman would have been excused
because we do have a young child at home
thank you i understand
thank you
know
so
could you kindly offer a comfort break i
would quite like one if they they're
leaving
um okay um five minutes cancer ian ward
cancer
another comfort break for five minutes
members
chairman i should be standing for a
while i shall be disappearing
necessarily
okay
thanks counselor
uh
[Music]
[Music]
members as time is pressing can i ask
that uh future questions and responses
are brief as possible please
um i shall now take item 1.4
on the agenda
of item 12
and that is in the hands of council mrs
mason
sorry could i ask councillor mrs mason
to
open this uh
motion please
thank you mr chairman i will try and
keep it brief this is just trying to
rectify a few years errors without
waiting a few more months
when i'm going to perhaps perhaps say
can we have a show of hands because if
everyone was ready it will save me
reading it out
um
but probably you don't go along with
that now
so
i'm going to move straight to the motion
rather than take time because i expect
this to go
the same way as every other motion that
we put forward
this motion calls for the monitoring
officer to resolve the situation
immediately and confirm the correct
status of planning policy with any
necessary amendments to the constitution
as needed at the next council meeting on
the 21st of april
so i can't be much briefer than that
thank you
council do you have a second uh
second thank you mr councillor wilkinson
councillor
thank you chairman
councillor mrs mason has raised her
concerns on this matter with officers
and he was looked into fully to
understand her concerns and issues
raised
council mrs mason thank you for that
the subcommittee was constituted by
annual council in may 2019
according to the pro writer rules it
makes no decisions on matters reserved
to the council
or the executive and reports directly to
the council on matters that reserve to
council
the issue is a technical one
it has been confirmed to mrs mason
council mrs mason that the council's
monitoring officer will be presenting
her annual monitoring officer report to
members in april
this issue will be included as part of
that report
therefore i can support this motion in
part
and so i do wish to move an amendment to
the motion to say
the monitoring officer will ensure that
the current planning policy subcommittee
will be constituted as a full committee
at the next annual council meeting thank
you councillor
council steptoe
i
pleasure secondly that too
members
any questions on an amendment please
no questions
counselor mrs mason
not unhappy with it but it's just that
it is now a committee of full council so
if we could have confirmed
um or can uh i'm quite
from what i heard i didn't quite get
what you read out
please yes thank you
just just for one word
thank you chairman um the monitoring
officer will ensure that the current
planning policy subcommittee
will be constituted as a full committee
at the next annual council meeting
thank you councillor
um i'm not surprised at that but i'll
tell you why i'm concerned i was told
last year
that there was nothing wrong with it
i bet we've been told year after year
and it took a lot of persuasion
to get officers to look into and it was
only this october and this is where the
concern comes in this october it was
confirmed that it was inaccurate um i
accept for the sake of a month i'm not
uh but
one thing i will correct you and we
weren't advised that the monitoring
officers report would be out in april we
would advise it would be out but not
exactly when so
yeah i'm quite happy to for that to go
through thank you
thank you uh members we have an amended
motion proposed by councillor rhones and
seconded by council steptoe those in
favor please indicate
that's unanimous members thank you
right um
we now go on to um
the motion again by mrs mason
if i could ask mrs mason once again to
uh present her motion please
it's a fourth motion thank you mr
chairman if i was less tired
i would summarise it but i can't and i
think this is
actually too important
to gloss over as the previous motion i
was able to
this scheme i have put the background
down it the ba hope foundation was set
up in 2018
to continue the legacy of
a paramedic i believe called billy
apathy hope which i've probably
pronounced wrong
a 20 year old ambulance driver from
bristol who was the inspiration idea
behind the billy chip
which is basically like a poker chip
um i will brief it for some of it
because i'm hoping that people have read
this
it turns out that most people are
apprehensive
about giving money directly to homeless
people because it's not possible to know
how that donation is spent
unfortunately the common perception
rightly or wrongly is that the money
will be used for alcohol drugs or
cigarettes
even if a donation of food or drink is
given to safeguard your donation it is
very awkward as people have to make
assumptions of what the person wants and
when they want it
the alternative is to engage with that
person ask the question
and then purchase what's required which
many residents quite understandably
feel uncomfortable doing
billy
recognized the likelihood of someone
having the time the inclination and the
courage and kindness to engage with a
homeless person to buy them food or
drink was a big challenge
and
he thought up this concept of a billy
chip
the billy chip is a token
that can be purchased by a two pound
donation via retail outlet which
supplies takeaway beverages like tea and
coffee
the purchaser receives the billy chip
which can be given to any homeless
person instead of money
the homeless person can redeem the billy
chip for any at any participating outlet
and hopefully you know this can be
extended
each time a donation for the billy chip
is received some of your money goes to
supporting the foundation
some to carry on work working home with
homeless people
as proportion of the donation goes to
the retailer to cover their costs and
the costs of supporting the
foundation's function so they're not
actually giving them two pound there is
an administrative cost that's built in
the brilliant and unique way the billy
chip scheme works
allows people to donate to the homeless
without the rarity of their donation
being spent in an inappropriate manner
it also encourages retail outlets to do
their bit for corporate social
responsibility
this the billy chip has received
national publicity for the way it
supports homeless and local businesses
it provides a degree of security to the
giver by removing uncertainty about the
use that their donation may be put to
it also alleviates the risk of people
receiving donations being able to use
those contributions for dependency
issues
although rochford district does not have
as many homeless people as some nearby
areas
the fact that the problem is a
relatively small one should not prevent
this council in being proactive in
assisting people in need
they're still our residents
the schemes sought to provide tea and
coffee
but there's no reason why outlets could
not extend this to food and soft drinks
and various value chips can be made
available every they're blue at the
moment every blue token
has billy's smiling face on it along
with a message you're fabulous and don't
ever forget it
and i think our residents are fabulous
and i think we ought to help them in any
way we can
having contacted the organization they
are willing to support rochester
district council in extending this
scheme to our area
as the scheme is already up and running
any costs involved should be minimal as
a two pound token covers retailers
expenses
motion directs the officers investigate
the scheme as a matter of urgency with
the future information implementation
until i'm tired through council before
the end of april 2020
it's urgent
homeless people
don't suddenly get housed they're
thirsty tired and hungry all the time
the simplicity and speed of using an
existing scheme to assist our
our homeless population
so i'm asking the council to note that
this council resolves to
undertake the necessary steps to ensure
that rochford district is included in
the scheme
promote the scheme with local traders
and look to extend the scheme to cover
food and different value tokens
i
i'm quite happy
if
members have read this and have picked
up anything that i've missed i'm happy
to make an amendment to my motion
but i do think it's a very important one
and i do think it's not something that
we should delay thank you
councillor mrs mason do you have a
seconder
yes thank you councillor webb
thank you thank you chairman
i would like to thank members of watch
your district residents for bringing
this motion forward and recognize the
good intent behind it
although we recognize that the current
estimated number of visible rough
sleepers is low in comparison to some
other essex authorities
our housing option team do continue to
manage an average of over 300 approaches
a month and are providing advice support
and intervention work
as you may know we have recently started
a partnership with chess the homeless
charity based in chelmsford who we have
partnered with locally to support rough
sleepers in the district
as part of this fast sleep initiative we
are working with four other neighbouring
authorities and essex county council
and as a group we have been successful
and been into the ministry of housing
communities and local government and
recently awarded together nearly just
over 400 000 pounds between the local
authorities and that's for government
funding to support those the most
vulnerable in our society
i have spoken with chess about this
scheme and i have suggested that other
schemes are also available for example
the greater change scheme
as we partner with chess and foot other
neighbouring authorities as part of our
new buffalo initiative we should be
aimed to be consistent in our approaches
as part of exploring this scheme and
those like it i would like to ask
officers to add this to this idea as a
topic of discussion for the rough super
initiative steering group and to see
what others think about introducing it
not just in this area but in the other
local authority areas as well
therefore i would like to amend the
motion to say in part four
this motion directs officers investigate
and explore this scheme and other
similar schemes with the view to
reporting back to council before the end
of june 2020
this council notes the simplicity and
speed of using an existing scheme to
assist our homeless population
this council resolves to undertake the
necessary steps to ensure that rocha
district investigates this scheme and
others like it
and then to promote the scheme with
local traders and to look to extend this
scheme to cover food and different value
tokens i've just changed a few words
there i have got copies of that
proposed in motion the amendment
i'm
[Music]
yeah if you could just uh i'll just read
through this and i want to amend my um
motion as uh the first sentence stays
the same
can i ask a question please counselor
where people promote this scheme uh
presumably you mean the chosen scheme
promote the scheme i understand there's
a number of different schemes i
understand there's a number of different
schemes out there sorry through the
chair sorry
yes i understand that your first one
undertake the necessary steps to ensure
that rightful district councils
investigates this scheme and others like
it but then you put promote the scheme
uh promote a scheme or yeah promoter
scheme thank you
sorry mr chairman but obviously we want
to get this correct look to extend the
scheme
to cover food and different value tokens
i'm quite happy to
move that emotion um
and i'll read it out again for clarity
that this council notes the simplicity
and speed of using an existing scheme to
assist our homeless population
this council resolves to
undertake the necessary steps to ensure
that rochefort district council
investigates this scheme and others like
it
this council resolves to promote a
scheme with local traders
looks to extend the scheme to cover food
and different value tokens and i believe
councillor webb through the chair if i
may um you put a date on that
i felt june was a a suitable time scale
just because officers have got obviously
yes as we've extended it to other
schemes yes
i'm quite happy um the report to be to
[ __ ] uh where do you want it reported so
full council i think it should come to
the forecast i'd be happy for full
council yeah
and so the final part of the motion is
the report to come to full council
by june 20. do you have a second for
those amendments mrs base council reeves
thank you
any questions on those amendments
members
no
council
motion
council web are you happy with those
amendment revised amendments thank you
chairman yes
i shall put that to the vote then
members if those in favor please
indicate
any against
any abstentions
thank you members that's carried thank
you very much
right
remembers the fifth motion has been
moved by councillor canel cancer canal
can you please present your motion
thank you chair thank you for the
opportunity i stand with more optimism
than some of my colleagues here this
evening i hope this is a motion that we
can all agree to
for context before i start there aren't
that many
uh accurate um recordings of figures of
eu nationals in our district however the
2011
census estimates around 1100
and the 2019
annual population survey predicts around
4 000.
the government have so far released
figures that suggest 336 applications
have been received from this district
with that context in mind i therefore
read the motion as it
has been shared with you
the united kingdom of great britain and
northern ireland left at the european
union at 2300 hours on january 31st 2020
in july 2017 the then prime minister
announced the outline for an eu settled
status scheme that would enable eu
nationals the right to continue living
working and studying in the uk after we
leave
in january 2019 the same prime minister
announced that following a pilot the eu
settlement scheme as it had become
formally known was to launch in march of
that year and that's a 65 fee that was
charged in the pilot would be removed
the current prime minister has continued
this scheme and has used prime
minister's questions as recently as
january 2020 to vocalize his support for
it
the scheme outlines two forms of status
settled status for those that have lived
in the uk for five years or more and
means they can reside in the uk forever
without reapplying unless they leave the
uk for a period of five consecutive
years
pre-settled status for those citizens
who started living in the uk by the 31st
of december 2020 but will have not had
five years continuous residence at this
point
it will allow people to reside in the uk
for five years at which point they can
apply for settled status
this council notes the invaluable
invaluable contribution of eu citizens
living and or working in rochford
district to the local economy and public
service provision
the council therefore resolves to
advertise the government's eu settlement
scheme and support any resident with
their application for settled status or
pre-settled status as described under it
support any resident who applied for the
eu settlement scheme before march 2019
to receive a refund of their 65 pound
fee
confirm that it believes that all
eu citizens in the district should
retain their right to vote and be
candidates in local elections
and pledge to support and protect all eu
citizens who live or work in the
district throughout the transition
period
thank you
councillor do you have a second for that
council newport thank you council
steptoe
thank you chairman um i will try and
rattle through this as quick as i can i
do have some uh copies of the words so
i'll pass these out whilst i'm speaking
yes thank you ask those out
it does say on the top of the sheet
there motion five but it's actually 1.6
so
please ignore that
uh cancel canal is correct
correct that following the uk's
departure from the eu except in a few
cases
who are who are now
those who are eu e a a or swiss citizens
and their families can apply for the eu
settlement scheme
to continue living in the uk after the
13th of june 2021
the eu settlement scheme is administered
by the government
via gov dot
uk
website
councillor canal asks
the council to note the invaluable
contribution eu citizens living out and
or working in rochester district to the
local economy and public service
provision and i'm sure all members will
agree with that
the council of canal
goes further
in that he asks the council to make
resolutions regarding the eu settlement
scheme
some of which cannot i cannot accept in
the form of which it is proposed
i have calculate circulated to all
members a copy of the amendment to the
motion
which i shall move at the conclusion of
this speech
council
proposes that the council resolve
to advertise the government eu
settlement scheme
and support any resident
with their application for settle stasis
or pre-settled status under the scheme
with regard to the advertisement of eu
settlement scheme
this council already does and will
continue to follow all government
requirements to communicate and promote
the scheme and i'm happy to support this
element of the motion
council canal also asked to resolve to
support
any resident
with their application for settle status
or pre-settled status under the scheme
as a local authority we are a major
provider of information
affecting people's everyday lives and we
often are the first point of contact
for a diverse range of people
on many important issues
we also have responsibility to sum up
for some vulnerable groups
this council will support vulnerable or
at-risk eu citizens
who are residents of this district by
raising awareness
and providing information as well as
signposting them to appropriate
support services to meet their needs
using the toolkit provided by the
government on gov dot uk
we also work with grant funded
organization organizations in our area
to expose how we can work together to
support eu citizens
i believe this type of support is
invaluable
and
and is the sort of support
this council can and should provide
but i want to be clear that this support
stops short of actually completing
applications on behalf of eu citizens
or assisting them
to complete applications as this is
something i believe should be undertaken
by those organizations who are pro
appropriately
qualified
and
and details of those organizations can
be found on gov dot uk
that is the reason behind my proposal
amended and
so i started that is the reason behind
my proposed amendment to that part of
councillor canal's motion
council canal also proposes that the
council resolves to support
any resident who applies for eu
settlement scheme before march 2019 to
receive a refund
of any fee that they may have paid
the process for receiving refunds is set
out on gov dot uk
and this is a person this is personal to
the applicant who must show that they
are eligible
i would therefore not be it would death
so
it would not therefore be appropriate
for this council to interfere with that
process although i agree that we do have
a role in signposting applicants to the
gov dot uk process
this is the reason for my proposed
amendment to that part of council of
canals motion
council canal pro proposes that this
council confirms
that it that it believes that the eu all
eu citizens in the district should
retain their right to vote
and be candidates in local elections
this is clearly a political point
and he will not be surprised that i
cannot agree to support that element of
the motion the law
clearly
the law is clear about who is or who is
not
eligible to vote as or be a candidate
the council will always follow the
requirements of the law
finally council canal proposes that this
this council pledges to support
protect all eu citizens who live work in
the district
through the transformation period this
is a political point and whilst i agree
in the sentiment
behind the motion i cannot agree with
the wording of it and that is why i
propose my amendment
this council will administer the law of
the land
comply with requirements and
communications from government
relating to eu exit and working with
partners
and working with partners will signpost
eu citizens within the district
to all the relevant information that
they need
throughout their transition period
currently members
i now move the amendments to the motion
set out on the paper in front of you
chair for information i will read it out
my amended proposal
is that this council notes
the invaluable contribution eu citizens
living
and or working in the rochester district
to the local economy and public service
provision
this council therefore resolves
to advertise the eu settlement scheme
and working with partners to provide
support to any vulnerable at-risk eu
citizen
resident by raising awareness and
providing information as well as
signposting them to the appropriate
support services to meet their needs
provide any information to any resident
who applied to the eu settlement scheme
before
march 2019
on how to receive a refund
work with partners to provide support to
eu citizens who live or work in the
district throughout the transition
chairman i so move that promotion that
amendment
thank you council do you have a second
copy for the chairman please
counselor i own you get your second nap
thank you very much
any questions on that amended proposal
motion council wilkinson
thank you chairman um chair i understand
the um the
basis behind well i think what the basis
behind the amendment and i just got a
one question to ask if i may um in the
first bullet point for the amendment
says um as well as sign posted them to
the appropriate support services to meet
their needs now i must confess that
prior to reading this
um
on the agenda for this evening i hadn't
even heard of this scheme
if i'm honest so do those support
services exist that we can signpost them
to i do understand the need to try and
push them to the right people but do
they exist thank you
okay any other questions
counselor canal
thank you chair
and thank you for um councillor stetson
um for taking so much time to read the
motion think about it and go through and
think about potential changes
um i do think some of the examples and
reasoning you've given are examples of
the type of support i was proposing or
intending to propose when i put this
forward
however
i can appreciate that written word can
be interpreted in different ways
so i don't have too much issue with most
of
the changes i do however notice that the
the third bullet point of the
original
motion
confirmed that it believes all uk
citizens in the district should retain
their right to vote and be candidates in
local elections
um
again i can appreciate the written word
and interpretation may have led you to
that conclusion but it wasn't intended
as a political point this was intended
as a point of showing that they are
still our equal they are still our
friends they are they are still people
we value um and things like being able
to to vote and stand as candidates would
confirm that they are their equal i'm
also not proposing that we change the
law with such
a bullet point it was simply confirming
that we believe that they should retain
i.e send them a message that they are
equal and that we respect them and that
we still want them here
um for those reasons um
in fact i'll leave it there chair thank
you thank you any other questions on the
proposed amended motion members
no
and i shall put that to the vote those
in favor please indicate
which goes against
any abstentions
thank you members that's been approved
thank you
members
it is now 11 o'clock
and i move without notice 9n set out on
page 4.23 of the constitution continue
this meeting before be beyond
beyond 11 o'clock do i have a seconder
councillor ward is that agreed members
okay
there are two more to come more to come
yeah
is that agreed
okay
absolutely
[Music]
the vote is whether to extend or not
yes so
can we just
if we don't extend we'll finish the
meeting now so
um
myself and counselor cannell
we're quite happy to defer our motions
to the next council meeting if that
helps thank you very much indeed for
that all right
in that case members i propose from the
chair that we
close a meeting at this moment and the
two other motions
be put to the next meeting thank you
very much
a closer meeting at
1102. thank you very much
[Music]
thank you
well it terry
that good
please stand for the chairman
he just got winged